[Music]
I'm the one
okay so our guest today is a fan
favorite she's been on before uh she
talks about stuff that uh people in
power don't want her to talk about you
know she's hidden in a place in the
world that nobody can find she doesn't
live in the states here she comes here
every once in a while does her thing
pisses the powerful people off and then
she leaves the country again she's
written a couple books one called One
Nation Under blackmail volume one and
then there's one nation under blackmail
volume two uh a professional writer
researcher and journalist since 2016
she's written for several websites and
from 2017 to 2020
was a staff writer and Senior
investigative reporter for mint Press
News she currently writes for the last
American Vagabond and hosts an
independent podcast called unlimited
hangout her Works aimed to highlight
underreported issues and find Common
Ground between people of different
political Persuasions regarding
corruption government overreach the lack
of accountability for militaries and
intelligence agencies and the military
industrial complex and she also talks a
lot about Epstein and a bunch of other
stores it's great to have you on that's
great to be back how you been joining me
I'm doing well good yeah fantastic so
from the last time till today we got we
got a lot of different things we want to
cover with you we got some ESG questions
for you we got some Dei Stories We Got
the Whole Soros and musk going back and
forth a little bit with musk tweeting at
him we got a Woody Allen story we got a
bunch of different things but from your
standpoint what's what's been new new
stories you've seen recently on Epstein
that's been creating momentum since the
last some we were together well I guess
the most recent one of course is going
to be these Revelations that have come
from the Wall Street Journal most
recently about his private calendar
um emails you know a bunch of different
things per the Wall Street Journal they
claim to have thousands of pages of
documents but I'm a little curious you
know where maybe they got these
documents from why now and if they plan
on publicly releasing any of that
because of course you know the reporting
comes from the Wall Street Journal and
they refer to these documents but none
of those have been released to the
public and I'm personally a big fan of
of public transparency but we're kind of
in a post Wikileaks world you know so to
not to get much of that Source reporting
anymore but I would definitely like to
see it considering a lot of the names
that have come out in connection with
that it's great seeing Wall Street
Journal doing this though right because
they can't say it's a website or it's a
blogger or it's somebody with this one
does it you have to give it to you have
to pay attention to it yeah but at the
same time you know and a lot of the
reporting the way it is is you know this
is what's in the documents and then we
talk to the person referenced and of
course the person distances themselves
from Epstein and says oh well I only
went to them because he was wealthy or I
didn't know anything about this or that
and it's hard to know if that's really
true to be honest because some people
have claimed that and then evidence has
come out showing it was a bit different
and then they're like oh well
and and nothing really happens you know
you referenced a a post Wikileaks world
right now obviously a reference to
Julian Assange break that down what does
that mean since that transpired what
over a decade ago I want to say what
where do you see the the current state
of affairs today so I sort of you know
uh looking at like Assange and Wikileaks
you know what they were doing obviously
before
um Assange was incarcerated uh was
taking Source documents that they
received and putting them out for the
public uh to look at and View and draw
their own conclusions and it you know
how investigative reporting has changed
since then is I think pretty clear I
mean you compare a lot of the how
Wikileaks handled you know their access
to Source documents versus something
like the Twitter files for example I
mean there's a pretty big
shift between then and now and
personally I prefer the the former model
because more information more
transparency I think that ultimately is
a and serves the public interest more
how does that affect reporters like you
today whistleblowers stuff like that
what the mindset of you guys doing this
intense investigative journalism how's
how things change well you know I
intentionally like what I do I don't try
and work with people that are in a
position to like have face jail time for
giving me information because given what
like I know and what's pretty obvious
about the surveillance state today I
don't feel like I can guarantee anyone's
security
let me ask how many people have actually
reached out to you who are insiders
saying hey can we talk offline because I
have some information that I want to
share with you I mean a couple but again
you know I don't live in the U.S so it's
hard for me just online to know that
they're for real and I don't want to
again put anyone in a position of danger
so I tend to go with things that are
public record open source but people
that do want to work with those types of
sources everything that's happened with
Julian Assange and Wikileaks and even
you know with um with what happened with
Snowden and then a lot of the people
that for example leech documents or
shared documents with the intercept for
example three of those guys went to
prison and that was after Snowden and
Assange so I think there's definitely
been an intentional chilling effect on
on that sharing of of transparency and I
think obviously that's in great
detriment what about your personal like
do you ever worry about them I mean
because it's completely positive they
could get to somebody in jail and say
that he committed suicide how he like
you do you fear for your own safety at
all well I mean people ask me that a lot
but frankly you know the state of the
world today
um I feel like it's incumbent on all of
us to stand up and say something and
again I'm not trying to work with like
classified information and stuff you
know I think if I was it would be a
different situation for sure
um but I think also at the same time
like if you live your life in fear
that's going to impede you from doing
stuff that's important
um and you know I'm really grateful for
the platform I have today
um and you know I have a I guess an
ability to put information together that
helps you know people see some of these
um you know power structures that aren't
necessarily visible to everyone
um and I feel like it's you know my duty
and responsibility to do that because
frankly you know the more people we
really need to raise awareness I think
about about these you know power
structures these situations and and how
we got here because you know especially
if you're a parent of
kids like I am I mean you know you just
let things keep going this way it's not
going to be good for anybody so you know
I like it I like what you're doing it's
dangerous someone's got to do it I got I
got a question to start off with here so
individuals subpoenaed in the usvi's
Epstein linked case against JPMorgan
okay you got Sergey Brin and Larry Page
you got must you got Michael orvitz he's
the former uh president of Disney uh and
the co-founder of creative arts you got
uh uh Mortimer Zuckerman you got uh
Thomas uh pritzker you got Glenn Durbin
you got Leslie Wexner which we talked
about last time you got John Luke of
Brunell and a few other uh isn't Brunel
dead well it's in your French modeling
Scout who was a closer he was he was
arrested in Paris I believe and uh died
in this jail sale
being a dead person I mean that's when
AI is really Advanced you can do that so
so this comes out but the problem with
this story is the fact that uh Newsweek
does a story a week go saying Larry Page
has been missing as Google founder faces
Jeffrey Epstein lawsuit the U.S Virgin
Islands that attempting to locate Google
co-founder Larry Page to subpoena him as
part of a lawsuit against JPMorgan Chase
but so far four possible addresses have
been found invalid the government
brought the civil action against def
defendant JPMorgan Chase Bank as part of
its ongoing effort to protect Public
Safety and to hold accountable those who
facilitated or participated in it
directly or indirectly the trafficking
Enterprise on Jeffrey anyways he keeps
going talking about this so what is if
they're going after these guys there's a
story about page missing there's another
story about Sergey brain going through
what he's going through how much are
they really going to get to the bottom
of this and is this just a nothing
Burger you know I don't know some of the
other cases I think to an extent were
sort of like nothing burgers and some of
these stories about past cases being
unredacted you know a lot of those
redactions it was actually kind of known
what was there this seems a little bit
different because this is the first case
I'm aware of where they're subpoenaing
so many billionaires yeah you know so
that should be kind of an indication
that they at least more than other cases
sort of seem to be interested in getting
more to the bottom of the money aspect
and again this is the JP Morgan case and
as I'm sure you all are aware uh the
Attorney General the USVI after filing
this case gets fired just a few days
after so of course there's a lot of
speculation that her firing was related
to her filing of this particular case
and you know when it comes to some of
these Tech billionaires I think that's
interesting too because you know in in
my work on Epstein you know there's a
lot to be said about the edge Foundation
Epstein was funding them very
extensively including being like their
only financing source for several years
it was run by publisher John Brockman
who was a science publisher and they had
this annual bill I think billionaires
dinner
they called it which brought Epstein
into contact with a lot of these big
Tech names and a lot of uh you know the
biggest names in Tech including Jeff
Bezos Moss Zuckerberg uh Brynn and Paige
you know have all come up in the Epstein
case even before these subpoenas
um so you know I think that's that's
pretty interesting and another thing too
that I came across recently is that a
lot of these big tech companies have
data centers in New Albany Ohio and the
land on which those data centers sit is
owned by the New Albany company which
Epstein actually set up for Leslie
Wexner and invested in and was a general
partner in that company at the time that
it was planned to court big Tech to that
particular area you know it's
interesting you're saying this we had
Mike Tyson on yesterday and he said
something so uh some of these like when
you're when you start doing business you
get invited to parties okay oh sure and
when you go to these parties you're like
hey meet this guy hey meet that guy hey
meet this guy hey meet that guy you're
like oh okay Greg hey meet this guy
Jeffrey Epson oh [__] you're that guy oh
damn somebody just took a picture here
we go this is what's going to start so
Mike Tyson's at an event in Phoenix and
he says this one guy comes if he can
pull up this picture Rob he says this
one guy comes he starts shaking my hands
and you know he looks very fragile he's
like man I felt so sorry for this guy
and he shook my his hands were really
small and he was timid I said listen if
anybody does anything to you I got your
back nobody can say anything to you and
uh he says great the next day the feds
come to him and they're like hey we see
this picture with you and him how do you
know this guy he says well did somebody
do something to this guy poor guy was uh
you know I saw him being bullied I want
to make sure he's being he says no we
want to make sure you're okay because he
is he killed eight people and shot 29
people what yeah this is Bill housner
yeah so there's a picture with Dale if
he can pull up the picture with him and
Mike Tyson when Mike Tyson said I was at
another fight a Taliban was sitting next
to me and the white supremacist was
sitting next to me and they asked why
would you go to again with a white
supremacist and a Taliban he says I
didn't go to a game with those guys they
just bought tickets right next to me
just so so how much of this this whole
thing with these names being dropped
it's kind of like Guilty By Association
man I was just I didn't do anything with
these guys I just met him at a party
well it's hard to know uh again because
a lot of people involved in this case
have not been very forthcoming and some
of the names on The subpoena list
there's a lot to say about their ties to
Epstein that has not really found its
way into mainstream reporting but again
uh with some of the cases it could be
just what they say you know I you know I
met them through this guy and that guy
um so you know again without greater
transparency it's hard to know but
allegedly the US Virgin Islands has
access to a very significant amount of
documents from JP Morgan and their
interest in subpoenaing a lot of these
Tech billionaires specifically is that
Epstein was referring them to the bank
and again Epstein's activities with JP
Morgan
um from what the USVI has said
um it was very clear from JPMorgan
documents that his activity at the bank
was not consistent with any client-based
business and that was supposedly what he
had at the time Epstein and so the money
flow was weird his relationship with
Executives at JP Morgan was weird so why
was he referring people uh to the bank
their speculating that it's related to
some whatever you know funny stuff
Epstein was doing he was trying to bring
in other people would younger girls
well in the case of just Stanley that's
true but again you know and I think we
talked about this last time as I see it
Jeffrey Epstein wasn't just a sexual
blackmail Mastermind he was also very
talented at the world in the world of
Shadow and Offshore Banking so anyone
that wanted to get involved in that
whether it's for things like tax evasion
or all sorts of stuff I mean that
doesn't necessarily involve sexual
blackmail or interest in a sexual
interest in minors right that's here's
the thing though this is the problem
though with with the Epstein story
because the only thing people think
about when they see a picture with un
Epstein if they see that online the
first reaction everybody gets they don't
think about tax evasion they don't think
about blackmail they don't think oh
exactly the only thing they think oh
this guy probably hooked up with a 14
year old girl so I understand what
you're saying in that sense okay he got
close to uh JP Morgan Chase and hey they
have this thing where he's brokering
deals and he's bringing money over to
them I can see that I can see how myself
you know I refer God knows how much
business to my advisor that I'm working
with at certain bank and he does my
stuff so when I bank with someone or I
use a technology or I use someone I'm
like go to this guy and they've probably
made a lot of money through those
referrals obviously this is at a larger
scale because he's bringing a billion
dollars half a billion dollars 300
million dollars and Jamie dimon is going
to take those accounts he's not going to
say no to it but the difference between
receiving that referral and the other
aspect of Epstein that's not only
Courier ending that's reputation that's
Legacy that could destroy your in in
your reputation in every way so if we
can isolate the two let's do that so
from your research this is your world
where
you study this you you've created so
much momentum right now what you're
talking about and the sources you're
referring to let's go one by one by one
Larry Page and Sergey grin Sergey Brin
based on the research you've done what
what have you learned about those guys
from Google okay so as far as Google as
a company goes from the very beginning
of that company they took um National
Security State money specifically CIA
money and throughout their existence as
a company like we know from the Edward
Snowden documents uh collaborated very
openly with the NSA and other national
security agencies uh to the you know and
sharing data in ways that they were not
you know public about with their their
customers and users and of course Google
dominates search so they have a huge
um role in the type of information
people access when they look for
something those first results what
results are first you know Google has a
lot of power and to take it back to
WikiLeaks for a second um if you
remember back um I believe Julian
Assange wrote a book called when Google
met Wikileaks basically talking about
how he his experience with that uh led
him to believe that Google was
essentially operating as an intelligence
agency in connection with the Hillary
Clinton run State Department
so and you know I think jigsaw at the
time
um which was part of alphabet had these
weird connections
um with you know things going on in the
Arab Spring and other geopolitical
developments where Google was alleged to
have played an outside role
um so it's important to keep in mind
those aspects of Google
um but you know as far as the connection
specific connection to Epstein goes uh
Larry Page I'm not necessarily familiar
with anything but before the subpoena it
was known that Sergey Brin was going to
the townhouse with Epstein in the early
2000s he was yeah and I think at least
one of those meetings Mort Zuckerman
who's listed on that subpoena list as
well was present that these were some
regular visitors to to his townhouse in
the early 2000s and it's possible as
well that you know this Edge Foundation
thing and again I'm not trying to say
Edge is a pretty big thing not everyone
that was part of edge was tied up with
Epstein but I think it's pretty clear
from the finances alone that Epstein use
that billionaire dinner and his big role
as the main fun for a long time of Edge
and being very close to Brockman to get
access to these big tech people you have
to keep in mind too that after Epstein
was busted for sex trafficking the first
time he tried to Rebrand as a big time
Tech investor
specifically and his big company that he
was trying to make out of the Virgin
Islands which I think he made in like
2012 was called Southern trust and he
framed it as being a biomedical and
financial Google he it was it was
described by the New York Times as a DNA
data mining firm so he's trying to get
in all these these spaces that also
Google and a lot of these other big tech
companies are also trying to get to in
relatively the same period of time
because 2012 is like 10 years ago you
know a lot of people are talking about
AI now and all of this stuff but Epstein
was trying to sort of corner this market
for the AI market for big Pharma and for
uh major investment Banks back during
that time and actually in these Wall
Street Journal
um reports that have come out recently
it mentioned that the Edmund de Ross
child group Aryan de Ross child named in
in those documents had entered into an
agreement with Southern trust I think
around seven million dollars that they
had contracted this AI Financial
algorithm uh company that Epstein was
making in the USVI
um so you know again the financial
services thing with Epstein is very
underexplored by mainstream media and
what you refer to there about the public
perception of oh you have your picture
with Epstein sure you're a pedo I would
blame all of that on mainstream media
because mainstream media is only
interested in talking about Jeffrey
Epstein's sex trafficking activities
from 2000 to 2006 nothing before and
essentially nothing I think it's uh to
protect a lot of powerful people that
engaged in financial criminality with
them and also um
also uh people like Bill Gates and Bill
Clinton
as well because a lot of that uh you
know their ties uh for example with
Gates that goes back to the 1990s
mainstream media says it was 2011 and
the reason I think they say that is to
Gates didn't have any role in Microsoft
at that time if you look back before
then there's a lot of gates and Maxwell
Family Ties to Microsoft and other
Microsoft Executives Linda Stone Nathan
mervold documented Epstein ties with
them back in the late 90s
um and I think you know if you take you
make the gates Epstein story just about
the Gates Foundation and not about
Epstein and Microsoft I think that's a
you know
I want to stay on this because we're
going to go to Gates and and uh Clinton
as well so Elon Musk Elon Musk being a
link to a name like this the the thing
that concerns me is the following here's
what concerns me
I have four kids as a parent or a guy
that's running an insurance company or
any business I always watch your Trends
to see if it's all of a sudden out of
whack someone's influencing you
negatively or you're about to go to a
bad place in your life so for example
if you're generally a person that
doesn't drink doesn't smoke weed doesn't
do drugs and you're pretty stable all of
a sudden you're doing stuff that you've
never done for 20 years I'm like
something's going on with this your
decision making is going this way or you
used to be good with this guy and this
guy was an enemy and this guy's a true
bad enemy all of a sudden you start
defending this guy out of nowhere in
front of people like hey that is not you
you've never really defended this guy
what does he now have on you so when I
see you know the questions with Elon
Musk is hey you know he announces CEO
the new CEO that's coming to NBC
Universal lady who comes in and you know
World economic Forum everybody's losing
their minds I asked the question I did a
poll the other day on Twitter
Rob if you pull it up I said the good
hire bad hire let's wait and see good
hire was six percent wow bad hire was
like 20 something percent let's wait and
see it was like 60 something percent
right on what people want to see but
when when that was made
the same day or the next day after he
made the hire you saw the article comes
out about musk you saw what Soros
article comes out and you see what's uh
musk out of nowhere if you want to pull
up what musk tweets at Soros the next
day calling him you know sorosis
Magneto I didn't see that oh you didn't
see this he said Soros was magnesium
yes I'm sure so he says the asaurus is
Magneto if you want to show this tweet
Soros reminds me of Magneto right and
this thing just takes off 42 million
views on this tweet so everybody's
responding I can't believe you said this
he's trying to do this the reality is
Magneto was also a guy that dealt with
the Holocaust and the story he's a
survivor of it and that's kind of what
he's going through so it's really caused
behind it anyways so my concern becomes
when somebody that's been here's what
I'm for I'm for this I'm for that I'm
for this I'm for we got to get off of
advertisers we got to be doing all
subscription all of a sudden you bring
in advertising agency a veteran in the
marketplace to go and get advertisers
and you know she's a BlackRock edifying
Larry Fink edifying fake news is not
real did something happen did they find
are they like that's the part that kind
of throws me off sometimes well I think
some of these there's you know I see
Elon Musk is a person who has like a
very specific Persona he wants to
project to the public and then there's
business musk right and I don't think
they're necessarily always the same
person so you know um for example Elon
Musk a lot of people maybe forget you
know he's a big military contractor and
also you know the space force that's
also an intelligence agency so he's
technically a military and intelligence
contractor in order to keep your
contracting business with those things
there's certain rules you have to play
by and certain things I would assume you
can and can't say or you'll lose those
lucrative lucrative contracts and if you
look at someone like Elon Musk in his
his business history a lot of his
companies would not have been successful
uh excess sorry would not have been
successful without significant subsidies
from the government so you know I feel
like in order to get those deals there's
certain rules you have to abide by to an
extent
um at least when it comes to your
business decisions and certain things
right so maybe he wants to project you
know this Persona of like I'm one of the
Bros I'm one of the guys you know I
believe in free speech and all of this
and certainly when he bought Twitter
that's what he said but then it became
you know oh yeah Free Speech but not
freedom of reach and now it's sort of
changing again with the appointment of
this new uh CEO and again you know I
don't really have any High Hopes And I
didn't necessarily when uh musk bought
Twitter just because I tend to be kind
of skeptical and I guess you could
probably say cynical about these types
of um types of people and you know I
personally just for my own um you know
experience with Epstein research I have
found a musk not to be very upfront
about some of those connections there so
for example you know he'll be like a lot
of people like to bring up the the
picture of him and galane Maxwell from
2014 he'll say he was photobombed and
all of this but but um he won't bring up
the fact well at least reporters seem to
have forgotten uh that Kimball musk his
brother who was uh who's on the board of
Tesla and SpaceX was introduced to a
member of Epstein's Entourage who had
dated Epstein and lived at the
apartments on 301 66 66th Street East
where all these traffic girls lived a
girl from there starts dating Kimball
musk and somehow Epstein is allegedly
granted access to SpaceX facilities and
tours and then his allegedly advising
Tesla according to the New York Times uh
reporter James Stewart who was told by
someone else that Epstein was advising
Tesla and then goes before Epstein's
2019 arrest and most of his public
infamy goes and asks him about if there
were rumors were true and Epstein says
yes and this is during a time when
mosque is saying he's trying to secure a
capital to take a Tesla private I
believe and this was allegedly involving
one of the Saudi uh wealth funds of the
Saudi government and at that time
Epstein was very a very very close
advisor to Muhammad bin Salman who had
recently come to power and if you
remember back to when the Epstein story
really the Scandal sort of broke in 2019
it wasn't just talking about his
townhouse having all these pictures of
him and Clinton and there were a lot
probably as much as Clinton of Epstein
with MBS Mohammed what's the
relationship kind of that's pretty
random for a Jewish businessman with
maybe ties to the Mossad to be doing
business with well Saudi yes Kingdom but
MBS yes but Muhammad bin Salman was
brought to power in a way that was a
very uncharacteristic for Saudi Arabia
you know there it's not father to son
hierarchy right it's like seniority
within the royal family usually it's
like elderly uncles that become the next
Crown Prince and whatnot and he was very
young in his 30s when he came to power
and he hammered out things like the
Abraham Accords with people like Jared
Kushner he was texting Jared Kushner all
the time who of course has a very close
uh relationship with the Netanyahu
family for example so again that seems
rather uncharacteristic as well and it's
very possible that you know given the
geopolitical plays in the Middle East
and North Africa a lot of that often has
to do with you know people that are
either for or against Israel you know
what government's going to Shifting the
balance of power there normalizing
relationships with Israel and so the
Abraham Accords obviously were a huge
step towards normalizing relation the
relationship with Israel and the region
and they may have seen um you know oh
there's this uh upstart Prince that's
really ambitious and if we can get him
in then maybe he you know he'll help us
push that normalization just a bit
further so you know there's a lot of
question marks there but it seems to me
that that may have been something to do
with it and I also think this might be
the thread to pull on to find out the
real reason Epstein was arrested in 2019
because if you think about who MBS took
out Muhammad bin nayef that that guy was
very very close to John Brennan who was
the CIA director and John Brennan was
very unhappy with mbs's rise to power
and if you have abstain close to MBS
John Brennan who's also a big guy behind
russiagate and all of this stuff and
around NBS you have Kushner right you
have you have Epstein it seems like
there's two intelligence linked factions
uh sort of duking it out and if I've
seen was on one side and the other side
sort of wanted to send a message to that
side
you know
this the article I think you're talking
about Jeffrey Epson claimed he was
helping Elon Musk find a new chairman
for Tesla this is part of it yeah I just
want the stories but again to me there's
two different stories uh the one is I
did business with this guy and Kimball
right now I think he's got a vertical
vertical farming company no yeah doing a
whole different thing this is before
this is before that yeah so two
different things so one for example I'll
give you a crazy story so I first come
to Florida okay I'm doing a project and
we're it's called Mafia States of
America we're having it with uh all
these uh ex-mob gangsters and people
that are in that world I go to this
restaurant Casa D'Angelo first day I go
there the person I'm having dinner with
is Michael Francis Michael Francis was
one of the top earners and the couple it
was a couple in the Colombo family and
he comes in and this Casa D'Angelo place
is ran by Italian so they know who he is
you know they're talking to him and
we'll grab a seat the next day next I go
there I go there with Chaz Palminteri
the actor from uh uh uh Bronx Tale and
he's done a bunch of mob movies and he
looks like so he's got a incredible
one-man show so he comes with me next
time okay great listen the third time I
go eat at this Italian restaurant I
bring Sammy to bulgarano okay and they
see Sammy they lose their minds like
holy [__] send me the book gravano the
former underboss of the Gambino family
is here he's sitting we're sitting in
the same table by the fourth time they
thought I was an Italian gangster okay
and I said no I'm from the Middle East I
am not I'm just interviewing these guys
because I have a relationship and I'm
interested in that world so we're doing
a documentary a show on this so the the
challenge becomes
sometimes when you're seeing people love
to jump to conclusion and say well this
is what's going on the part I want to
isolate is the following with musk I
think what musk is doing you know 100
there's the argument of what he's taking
from public uh you know government and
plenty Government funding SpaceX all
this other stuff even Tesla he has to
answer to that and that's part of you
know capitalism where you're getting
money all this stuff that's a different
story
the part that I want to isolate is him
being linked to what Epstein did with
the curls there is nothing there with
musk uh no not that I've seen with the
girls but there are significant business
ties and what I just mentioned is part
of that another part I cover in my book
it's related to these brothers that uh
worked for Epstein and his brother Mark
Epstein and Osa properties which has
been tied to the sex trafficking
operation those apartments I mentioned
earlier owned by Osa properties
so one of these two brothers Jonathan
Barrett that worked directly for Epstein
and then worked for Mark I've seen at
OSA properties works for this company uh
called luminous and luminous is an
affiliate or related to LS power LS
power is a major supplier to Epstein and
they a lot of these directors for
luminesce for example are the same
people that were directors for the
special investment vehicle that Epstein
had with bear Stearns called liquid
funding and also
um investment vehicles and companies
tied to glencore which is Mark Rich
who's a well-known affiliate of um well
pretty much openly referred to as a
Massad asset and stuff like that he was
a Commodities trainer a Trader a
fugitive uh from the U.S for a long time
because of um helping Israel avoid the
the Oil Embargo of Arab Nations
um but for example he was pardoned by
Clinton really controversially allegedly
this was due to a lot of pressure put on
Clinton by ahud Barack at the time and
things like that so anyway
um you have sort of those shared
connections and the Kimball musk thing
and then you have a woman named Nicole
junckerman that I wrote a lot about in
the book who has invested in recent
years very extensively in SpaceX and
Nicole younkerman
um
maybe I should backtrack a little bit
before getting to Nicole so basically
what I note in my book is that there's
the sex office sex trafficking operation
of Epstein everyone knows about but
there seems to have been another
parallel operation that he used for
influence Ops I guess you could say
involving women but they were of age
they were women that were well educated
in some cases and probably most of the
cases but at least a few cases we know
about Epstein Finance their graduate
education and helped connect them they
ended up marrying or dating powerful
people sort of in his Circle so
allegedly Trump is one of these guys
right so his girlfriend before Melania
Selena middle fart Epstein was taking
her yeah horrible horrible man well
she's she's Norwegian she's Norwegian so
maybe in Norway
it's spelled farts middle fart yeah
she's a Norwegian heires very attractive
despite the last name I guess
um yeah so that probably helped her out
yeah but you know she and a couple of
these other women that Epstein was
taking to the Clinton White House in the
90s ended up marrying very powerful
people
um and she dated Trump and then
allegedly Melania was introduced to
Trump by Galena and Jeffrey Epstein they
claimed that who claims that
um I think it was either galane or or
Jeffrey Epstein at some point before
their Infamous that's how Trump met
Milan there's there's that allegation
that they were introduced to each other
you know but the modeling and the
strength thing with Epstein galane
remember this is before they were
Infamous necessarily at least publicly
and uh Trump likes models I think we all
know that that's not breaking news yeah
but I mean it's not like it was oh look
meet Melania who's underage at the time
right right it wasn't like that so again
you know if you're trying to secure
influence with powerful people and you
don't think they're susceptible to your
sex blackmail op involving minors you
can be the Matchmaker that sets them on
the path to marital bliss right because
you know whoever sets you up with your
husband or wife you might keep contact
with for a long time or if they come to
ask for a favor you might be willing to
do so right so there's a few other cases
where this happened and one of these
women is Melanie Walker that we can talk
about later because she's part of the
Bill Gates Epstein connection this
Youngerman lady I'm curious yeah so uh
Nicole younkerman is appears to be
another one of these women she's not an
Instagram model no but she was a model
she's a former model and now she uh is
married to some Italian oil billionaire
um very very wealthy he's much older
than her I think I saw that yeah he's 63
or something like that 66. and she's
she's very attractive right um
yeah something like that yeah and so
um allegedly you know there was this
meeting in in September 2002 in the
United Kingdom at a home that is owned
by Wexner and Nicole younkerman was on
Epstein's arm with a unknown brunette
woman woman and was passed off to these
two U.S senators that were there and the
allegation the the the implication there
which this is right before the Iraq War
vote
right the allegation is that there may
have been some sort of like sexual
blackmail occurring there but why is
Nicole younkerman hanging out with
Epstein and these Senators at this at
this place it's a bit weird and then um
there's some other business connections
over the years so for example carbine
9-1-1 which is this um
sort of on emergency 911 call center app
or something like that that's being sold
all over the United States it was
created mainly by Veterans of unit 8200
which is an Israel's signal intelligence
agency it was chaired and one of their
main investors was ahud Barack who of
course we know by now is very close to
Epstein and Barack urged Epstein to
invest at least of what we know at least
a million dollars into that company and
apparently Leslie Wexner also invested a
lot of money and at that same time of
course ayud Barack was getting a bunch
of money from the Wexner Foundation or
some weird stuff going on there but one
of the directors at the time when ahud
Barack was on the board and pinches
bucharist who's former commander of unit
8200 and some of these other guys on
this network Nicole junckerman's on the
board of directors as well and now she's
invested in in SpaceX so she's one of
these sort of Bond girls I guess you
could say that was sort of around
Epstein in this category with Melanie
Walker and now you know you know you
know what it is for me like I
you can't control who invests into your
company okay uh uh you can and you can't
I mean let me rephrase that yeah but to
an extent so take Elon Musk and Twitter
for example what does Elon Musk want to
do with Twitter he wants to make it X
the everything out and he specifically
as a model for that refers to WeChat
right and a lot of people don't really
like WeChat at least in the US because
it has so much data about everything you
do and if data is the new oil as is
often being said whoever owns the
everything app is going to own most of
the data they're going to be the new Oil
Barons the data Barons of this era the
new Rockefeller there's no question
about it right yeah yeah so WeChat the
same parent company of WeChat is a major
investor in Tesla and their most active
shareholders so it's kind of weird a
little Chinese company yeah so I think
it would be you know why does he want to
replicate the same thing which is a big
investor in who no the parent company of
WeChat I think it's 10 cent if I'm not
mistaken big investor in what in Tesla
in Tesla
and he wants to repl bring WeChat here
right you know I personally you know if
you're against the weft sort of like you
know musk postures about being against
the WAFF and they're all about this type
of you know Digital Life well let's
start yeah World economic Forum but it's
not just exclusive to them right there's
a lot of other interested parties
including Bill Gates for example a big
force behind ID 2020 and all of that a
lot of this particular Network's very
interested in creating sort of this
everything app because everything you do
finances social media all of it is in
one centralized place and you get all
that data what is this ID 2020 what is
that uh it's a public-private
partnership that was overseen it was
created under the Aegis of the uh or the
auspices of the United Nations and I
think it's the Rockefeller Foundation
um and it's um some other non-profits
that were created by the Gates
Foundation like gavi the vaccine
Alliance but Bill Gates is a big
proponent of of this whole digital ID
Paradigm for sure yeah
but I mean the benefit of it if you're
one of these guys you know you get all
the data and you can sell it to security
agencies you can sell it to whoever
right because if data is the new oil
that's the way to make money so you get
everyone's data on that app that's one
thing but at the same time keep in mind
too musk is a military and intelligence
contractor and historically if you look
at the Ambitions of the national
security agencies as it relates to mass
surveillance they wanted a thing like
that for a very long time
have everyone's data in one place we can
know exactly what they're doing at all
times and then also there's this
interest on on their part as well of
using AI to predict what will happen
sort of this pre-crime Paradigm in a
sense like a Minority Report yeah it's
happening before it even happened well
it's been being piloted or has been
piloted in the past by companies like
palantir Peter teal who you know did
PayPal with musk right the predictive
policing and actually William Barr under
Trump uh created a pre-crime program in
the United States called deep under the
Department of Justice that has arrested
some people for their social media posts
and and stuff like that arrested for
their social media under under the guys
that they're preventing mass shootings
before they happen well that was at the
time that was the big concern at the
time right there's a there's a part of
that there's a part of that that it's a
slippery slope it is but but Predictive
Analytics take take data out like
Predictive Analytics if you want to go
have a job that's going to be protected
for you for decades if you want to major
in something that's going to be safe go
major and Predictive Analytics
everybody's time analytics there's a
form of Predictive Analytics that's
without data a teacher watches a kid in
school and says that's the behavior
you're showing this guy is capable of
doing something he's been caught with
this has been caught with that and they
go and they talk to other teachers and
say let's keep an eye on little Joey
that's a formal Predictive Analytics to
say that this guy's going to do
something stupid or that kid's going to
do something stupid I get what you're
saying I've seen Minority Report and you
know it's a slippery slope totally get
its slippery stuff the problem is when
you give those rights away to the
government you're not going to get them
back there's no question about it they
keep going you know what I saw today
which was great I saw a video a Rob I'll
send this to you of uh of what's his
name that validates kind of your point
of uh who's this fantastic president of
Canada that everybody
the sweetheart of a guy who was the
Castro I think uh
but I want to send this to you so this
is this kind of validates what you're
saying Rob if you can just play this
real quick so here's a clip of what he
said about
um
about guns uh uh 12 years ago or 10
years ago and he says the one thing
about Canada and he's talking in a very
nice way he does that doesn't it you
know this is Canada we are gun loving
they can never take our guns you know
this we're never going to do this
they're like what what a sweethearted
guy right and then you know 12 years
later
effective today no in Canada we will you
know no more what happened to this guy
so you have to hear this because it
validates what you're saying if you can
play this clip that's predictive that is
not letting you it's not loading it's
not loading let me just play it from
here well while you guys are waiting the
other thing I want to add about this
productive analytics stuff oh go for it
no go is that the problem is a lot of
these AI algorithms they're not 100
accurate right so if you're making a
decision of whether or not we imprison
this person based on the AI and you're
working with something that based
according to the company is like 76
percent accurate it which is you know
not unheard of in this in that
particular industry and you know a lot
of times these are what the business the
figures the business puts out they're
not independently audited so it could be
50 which is like flipping a coin and
you're deciding whether or not to take
someone's Liberties away
oh my God you know based on that it is
that's another reason why I think it's
particularly problem so so so that's so
that's one topic we just went through
the Elon Musk and and it's more who's
investing is the your question is is he
more of a freedom guy or does he have to
at times you know agree for certain
things because hey if you do this we'll
give money to this and we'll fund this
and we'll okay I can see where somebody
could be tempted to make a decision
politically for other benefits that
could come they're fine but there's no
such thing with the younger girls with
him not not that I've seen fantastic so
let's say that's that's that's why I
want to kind of isolate these things
let's go to the next one the next one
that's a uh uh we can talk about is
Clinton and Gates if you want to kind of
uh get into that part I'll you know read
one story to you and then you take it
from there Bill Clinton's Aid linked to
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself with a
shotgun despite no gun I mean I gotta
tell you I've spent a lot of time you
know I've seen the uh Kappa fell you
know what's his name Richard uh David
Copper David Copperfield and some
magicians these guys they're great but
the ability for the clintons to do magic
like this I don't think they give him
enough credit for how great they are in
doing magic right Mark Middleton a
former advisor to President Clinton was
founded in May 2022 in Haifa Ranch in
Perryville Arkansas he was discovered
hanging from a tree with a gunshot wound
in his chest despite no evidence of the
weapon that killed the Middleton had
ties to convict the child trafficker
Jeffrey Epstein repeatedly signing him
into the White House during his tenure
as Clinton special advisor the
investigation into Middleton's death by
Perry County Sheriff's Office raises
more questions than uh answers
Middleton's body and Carr were found at
high first Ranch which is owned by
non-government organization allegedly
connected to the Gates Foundation and
Clinton Foundation the release of the
investigation report was delayed due to
Middleton's family's concerns about the
publication of harmful un uh
substantiate substantiated and hateful
articles on the internet the judge
allowed the
dissemination of certain details but
prohibited the release of images
Middleton had a controversial history
including being implicated in exploiting
his access to impress business clients
while working at the White House in the
90s so how do you do that I mean how do
you kill yourself with a shotgun and
hang yourself at the same time Mark
Middleton again this is another reason
why no one I don't think mainstream
media lets anyone talk about the Clinton
Epstein relationship before the year
2000 or until at Clinton left office
Mark Middleton was a central figure in
some very significant clinton-era
scandals it was not just him abusing his
access to the White House after he left
I'll give you an example Congress was
investigating Mark Middleton but at the
time 9 11 happened and of course 9 11
happens they move on to other stuff
obviously but before then the bishop the
Bush Administration George W Bush's
first time invoking executive privilege
was to block the release of documents to
Congress uh about a couple of about
three different things one of those was
Mark Middleton why is Bush stepping in
to protect the Clinton aide
that should tell you that there's
something bigger there with Mark
Middleton and then if you look at when
Mark Middleton was called to testify as
part of these investigations he pleaded
the fifth 28 times including to the
question are you a foreign agent wow so
there's obviously a deeper story here
the question is why wasn't Mark
Middleton uh you know suicided whatever
you want to call it back then it you
know why did it happen so recently I
would argue it's because in 2019 when
the Epstein case broke it was alleged by
The Daily Beast that Epstein had only
had five meetings with Mark Middleton
and then you find out from Daily Mail
gets White House visitor logs a couple
of months maybe like four months before
Mark Middleton's found dead it was uh
around 15. it was much higher
something was going on and then if of
course you go and look at what was Mark
Middleton involved in at the time he was
meeting with Epstein and what was
Epstein doing it starts to get really
weird Epstein at the time he was meeting
with Mark Middleton on behalf of Leslie
Wexner was involved in re note
renegotiate negotiating the relocation
of Southern Air transport from Miami
Florida to Columbus Ohio where it would
ostensibly be mainly running cargo for
wexner's company The Limited
have you ever heard of Southern Air
transport
so then her transport used to be air
America it was the cia's proprietary
Airline and Wexner bought it he bought
the bunch of those well he didn't buy it
but he basically pulling levers got a
very attractive incentive package
developed by the government of Ohio
taxpayers on the hook to relocate
Southern Air transport Promises of
bringing all these jobs which never
materialize uh and basically Southern
Air transport gets pumped and dumped and
goes bankrupt a few years after this
move by the into the 90s but anyway it
was being in 19 in the 1980s it was the
main Airline for Iran Contra arms and
and weapons dealing and then gets
involved with some weird stuff going on
with uh the go the first Gulf War and
with that history that is the specific
Airline sought out by Epstein and Wexner
they could have gone for any other
airline in the U.S there's a lot they
first tried one called Arrow air also
tied to Iran Contra and also the BCCI
scandal then they go to this polar Air
Cargo which is a joint Partnership of
three companies one of which is Southern
Air transport the other two guys Cook
Out Southern Air transport The Limited
dumps polar Air Cargo and goes straight
to Southern Air transport they seem to
be very desperate for some uh one of
these Shady Airlines and Southern Air
transport previously like I said was in
Miami Florida and during Iran Contra of
course it was going to Latin America
Mena Arkansas or Clinton's Governor all
this weird stuff's going on yeah and it
goes to Columbus it starts going from
Columbus to Hong Kong that's the that's
the circuit it's going what is Mark
Middleton doing during this period
period mark Middleton is a central
figure in a largely forgotten
clinton-era Scandal called China Gate
that intimately involves a bunch of um
very weird business ties between
Southeast Asian conglomerates mainly the
Lipo Group which had gone into business
with uh the Chinese government by this
time and a bunch of very very weird
stuff happens
um I don't know how deep you guys want
to go into that Scandal because it's uh
very convoluted very extreme but
basically you know I would say sort of
China Gate in a sense is a misnomer
because what is really going on here is
that this is the riyadi family in
Jackson Stevens so I do want you to talk
on the reality family okay if you can
touch on that yeah sure so the riyadis
on our uh I guess ethnically Chinese but
they've been in Indonesia for a very
long time they're one of the main
oligarchs in that country
um their main business interests for a
long time has been based around the Lipo
Group which has a bazillion
subsidiaries all over the world mainly
concentrated in Southeast Asia but also
of course a U.S subsidiary as well which
was run by this guy named Johnny Huang
who at the time of China Gate who was a
major guy in the China Gate scandal and
sometime in the early 80s the riyadis uh
you know got involved in Little Rock
Arkansas and be forged an early
partnership with Jackson Stevens who's
one of these Arkansas businessmen
political King makers he was uh he's
largely seen as being responsible for
Clinton's political rear from a career
from Arkansas onward but he also for
example financed the campaign of George
Bush Senior sort of playing both sides
and a lot of his companies that he ran
Stevens Inc Beverly Enterprises
systematics have either been tied to
Major Clinton corruption scandals of the
past or to Iran Contra specifically in
the in the case of systematics so the
riyadi family and Jackson Stevens had
these intertwined business dealings and
basically you know become sort of this
Hub of political cronyism in Arkansas
and of course Clinton gets into the
presidential office and it you know is
much more uh expansive than that at that
point meaning Beyond Arkansas obviously
um so basically what was going on with
China Gate I guess you could say is that
a bunch of money from foreign Nationals
mainly Chinese Nationals a lot of them
with ties to the Chinese government or
the Chinese military are being funneled
by through a series of individuals who
can donate to the DNC or the DNC is
directly taking money from people that
are foreign Nationals who of course
can't legally contribute to campaigns
and so you know that was the focus of
the Congressional investigation that it
was like illegal fundraising but what
was that money buying these people it
was almost all focused on the Commerce
Department the head of the Commerce
Commerce Department department at this
time is Ron Brown who of course uh dies
on their very suspicious circumstances
near the end of this when it starts to
come out in the 90s I think 96 or so
um dies in a plane crash but he has a
bullet wound in his head
um
well here's the thing the part of the
Commerce Department that was most
targeted by China Gate the ITA all the
other people on the plane with him
pretty much were ITA except for Johnny
Huang wasn't on the plane because he'd
been let go by that point uh but right
before Ron Brown gets on that plane to
Croatia uh he was going he agreed to
investigate or cooperate with an
independent Council probes into this
stuff
And he as unexpectedly asked to go on a
trade mission to Croatia
um and then the plane crashes allegedly
blamed on a 1930s era navigation system
at the airport in Croatia but a few days
after the crash the head of the
navigation at that Croatian airport is
found dead with a shotgun wound to the
chest in its rule to suicide
so there's some weird stuff going on
with China Gate to say the very least
but again I I think it's really more of
a misnomer there's a lot deeper corrupt
corruption here and I talk about it
pretty extensively in my book going
through the Congressional the Senate
reports and all of that and some of the
main things that seem to be going on
there it was about getting the Commerce
department and the Clinton
Administration to push for most favored
nation trading status with China and to
um after there was a certain point where
in exchange for that Clinton had banned
the import of Chinese weapons to the
United States
as sort of the caveat for giving China
mfn status
and before then the biggest market for
Chinese weapons was the United States so
they're smuggling weapons into the U.S
and they get caught doing that on some
Chinese state-owned barges coming to the
West Coast but then you have to wonder
what was going on with Southern Air
transport
going from Hong Kong to Columbus and if
you think about I think we talked about
this last time Epstein had these weird
associations with arms deals and Iran
Contra was mentored by an arms dealer
named Douglas Leese who had you know all
sorts of connections to the to the
defense industry both in Britain and the
US uh he's a British guy though and uh
that's the guy that connected him with
Stephen hoffenberg of towers financial
and the Ponzi scheme that was ran there
and Epstein's name was dropped from the
case hoffenberg took the the hit and
instead of Epstein going to prison he
starts hanging out with Robert Rubin at
the White House who's a former head of
Goldman Sachs
there's a crazy I don't know I mean
there's so much we could get into with
the whole like Clinton Epstein thing in
the 90s again this is why I say they
only talk about Clinton and Epstein
after Clinton Clinton left office
because they don't want you looking at
all this crazy stuff question for you so
yeah my what frustrates me and like
almost inferior infuriates me is when
you're selling out America okay
and you know when you make it to the top
the question for me to be would be the
other way
who which one of our presidents have we
had that hasn't sold America to somebody
else for their own personal benefit I'm
being very serious no I know well
sold America let me go back to for a
second because there's a Biden
connection so basically
um one of the other guys that was
targeting the Clinton Commerce
Department was this guy named Bernard
Schwartz who was a major military
contractor uh Laurel was his company he
later sold a bunch of it off to Lockheed
Martin because of the head of Lockheed
Martin at that time was his really good
friend Norm Augustine and Norm Augustine
goes on a few years later to make
inqutel for the CIA
um but Bernard Schwartz basically was
trying to use he was the biggest donor
to Clinton legal donor to the Clinton
campaign in 96 where all this China Gate
stuff was happening and he was
specifically trying to get satellite
export controls moved from the state
department to the Commerce department so
Ron Brown would handle it and Ron Brown
he'd basically given a bunch of Ron
Brown had been DNC chairman before this
and had been involved in a lot of this
funny funny stuff going on the guy who
got shot in the head was a former DNC
chair yeah yeah and then he was Commerce
Secretary so so um Bernard Schwartz was
basically trying to do technology
transfers to the Chinese military I
don't really know why but he was very I
mean if you look at the documentation of
what Laurel was doing who it was selling
it to in the broader China Gate stuff
and again this is coming from the
Congressional report like I'm not even
relying on mainstream media here this is
the US government investigation
Bernard Schwartz has a lot to answer for
but again because 911 happens everyone
forgets about this stuff right because
it's like oh that was the last
Administration we have a lot of bigger
stuff to deal with now right so Bernard
Schwartz it turns out uh was the one of
the top if not the main donor to Biden's
primary campaign in 2020.
um
Bernard Schwartz Bernard Schwartz and he
was the the single largest contributor
to the Democratic party 92 through 96 in
1998 for her 71st birthday party he
celebrated his birthday I think at the
White House with the clintons probably
that would sound about right yeah very
close uh-huh but this is a guy that was
selling our like most sensitive military
satellite technology to the pla so to
again to me who who hasn't sold America
and what happens to those guys okay if
you were to go back and you were to say
you know these are the these are the
people at the top that didn't sell out
have you investigated that because to me
that's just as important as who has sold
out
yeah so I mean you come across I I mean
frankly you know looking at someone like
Ron Brown he was corrupt but he was
going to it you know
work with the investigators and he gets
killed off what kind of message does
that send to other people at the ITA in
the Commerce Department that we're gonna
testify to Congress
you want to end up like Ron Brown
so you're saying that behind closed
doors those types of talks are happening
where I think it's very possible most
definitely yeah
um I mean to think it wouldn't uh I
don't know
um
again it's hard to say because I don't
know I'm not there I don't have access
to those documents but I think it's
pretty clear you look at something like
the FBI for example more recently there
is apparently an FBI document that has
been requested by Congress that shows
Biden engaging in play-to-play politics
with a foreign National the FBI won't
release it or isn't the FBI you know no
one's Above the Law all this stuff
everyone's supposed to be on the same
playing field oh you know if that type
of corruption really was happening in
the U.S the FBI would investigate it for
sure why don't they
well I think you just kind of have to go
back and look at the history of the FBI
you know it's a lot of these people like
J Edgar Hoover and and people like that
have sort of been given this mythical
legendary status they're Paragons of
morality you know all this stuff but if
you look back at like Hoover for example
an insane amount of mob associations or
mob linked businessmen
um he was obsessed with blackmail
acquiring it on friend and foe um he was
uh involved in power struggles with the
early intelligence Services about who
was going to have more control over
America according to a case that was won
uh by Martin Luther King Jr's family in
the late 90s uh Hoover's FBI was
responsible for killing Martin Luther
King Jr
a killing
FBI linked to kill a Martin Luther King
Jr yeah there was a Civil Trial that was
brought by King's own family
and they said and the result of that was
yeah it was the FBI
Winnie I have a question and that was
the 60s so if nothing happened to them
then what do you think's going on now I
you know my problem is that I feel like
you know thinking about like my own
family for example and how they like
view my work or my grandparents people
like that you know this the way they
were told things worked is not the the
way things were really working then
and a lot of the American public in my
opinion has sort of been fed this fairy
tale that the government is your friend
the government's here to help but
essentially if you look at the history
the government's the mob
or they act like the mob they well
they've it's funny everything that they
arrested the Mobsters for they've been
doing it but it's consolidation you know
what I mean yeah
like I don't think the mob went away I
mean if you look at a lot of these
people including the ones I talk about
in my book so let's take Chicago for
example some of the most powerful
families in Chicago to this day are the
pritzker family Thomas pritzker subpoena
right he's he's in Epstein's black book
numeral is the governor of Illinois
right now yeah Thomas pritzker in
Epstein's black book Epstein referred to
him as numero uno number one what does
that mean and they're the the legendary
Hyatt Family yeah they took over the
Hyatt hotels in the late 50s but they
were also involved through their lawyer
in something called Castle Bank one of
the most notorious intelligence and
organized crime-linked offshore banks in
the world it was set up by their lawyer
Burton Cantor uh and Paul hellewell who
was a big like American intelligence guy
Republican Insider so there you have you
know Democratic family Republican
Insider both parties coming together
teaming up with organized crime and
intelligence uh running offshore stuff
meaning neither party has a monopoly
absolutely
no not at all like I said Jackson
Stevens funding both sides exactly I
mean there's a ton of this going on so I
mean both parties I think are rotten to
the core unfortunately who but has
anybody that that that's been the least
to manipulate that's been the least to
take advantage of anybody
um
Obama Reagan Trump well Obama Obama's
whole political career he owes to the
pritzkers and the Crowns who are both
tied up to the same organized crime
intelligence power Nexus out of Chicago
that um Gus Russo who used to work for
PBS very acclaimed journalist wrote a
book about it called super mob
um about Sydney korshak this labor
negotiator in Chicago
um and how he basically exported that
power Nexus of organized crime and
intelligence from Chicago to La
um creating you know MCA Universal
Studios all of that stuff you know it's
the same blob basically but the
pritzkers
are in have been in that world for a
long time uh and you know Obama was
their guy 100 and uh one one thing I do
want to bring up uh the CIA director
under Biden William Burton's meeting
with Epstein right
so allegedly he was me he was going from
working under Hillary Clinton for a long
time as secret in the state department
uh to the private sector and that's what
he wanted to meet with Epstein and he
goes to the work to run the Carnegie
endowment and the Carnegie endowment the
chair of that is I think it's Penny
pritzker one of the pritzkers
so interesting and by the way
um what I'll be talking about yeah one
of the things I'll be talking about at
the Bitcoin conference is how during
that time when William Burns was running
it before he was picked to be Biden CIA
director was developing policy papers
with the Federal Reserve and the biggest
banks on Wall Street to end the
fragmentation between Banks the National
Security community and banking
Regulators basically calling to merge
Wall Street banking regulators and the
CIA all into one
interconnected blob
and then Biden's like I want that guy
for CIA director
because according to this policy
document developed by Carnegie with
input from the fed and JP Morgan and all
of these guys the only reason there's
global economic instability is because
of fragmentation between those three
actors so let me let me ask this crazy
question it's crazy here's a question
question for you
um you know
when you read a Reagan's book uh uh and
you read about him he also learned how
to negotiate with the other side Tip
O'Neill they would sit down they would
talk they would do this they would do
this so there was elements of him
willing to negotiate and he was loved by
a lot of people right sure he was loved
by the left or right for the most part
people liked him okay so he knows how to
do that but Trump there isn't any of
these organizations that you don't trust
that like him
so there's there's a part of that where
it's kind of like why does the FBI hate
Trump why does the CIA hate Trump why do
why does the Biden why do these people
that are in these power plays that have
been using this part why do they all
hate Trump as much as they do I think
it's a different faction I don't
necessarily think I don't look at this
stuff in terms of good guys and bad guys
I see them as competing power factions
yeah so there's two broad as I see it
power factions at play here there's the
people
that are like in power right now and uh
give you an example Anthony blinken his
stepfather Samuel pisar Robert Maxwell's
lawyer Armand Hammer's lawyer um big guy
um they describe him as human rights
lawyer he was a lot more than that
that's for sure he testified to Congress
at what was going on in the early this
is the early 70s he was saying yeah so
basically the nation state is already
irrelevant and we're building a single
uh unified World economy and we're doing
it because private Capital
um and private Western capitalist
Enterprises have decided to get in bed
with communist state-run Enterprises and
we're just going to make uh you know the
trans ideological Corporation he called
it this is what's going to run the world
now
he said it to Congress in the early 70s
and the congressman asked him is do you
see this as good or evil he was like
mostly good and this is the guy that
raised the guy that's running the state
department right now
and how closely tied was he to the world
economic Forum that entirely Samuel
Samuel pisar you know this was one so he
was really involved in this uh American
Committee for U.S Soviet relations and
he had a lot of big names on there
um and I talk about it in my Jamie
Diamond uh piece because controlled data
Corporation was involved with that and
there were very shadyly involved with
some of this Tech transfer stuff going
on his Samuel piser said one of the main
drivers of this trans ideological
Corporation were illegal Tech transfers
mainly from the U.S and the West to
Russia and China like what was going on
in China Gate but it was going on way
before then and a lot of these
businesses were doing stuff like that
that doesn't answer my question well I'm
getting there sorry it's kind of
long-winded so you have in that same
group wanting to commit that same you
know move toward that same policy goal
of the trilateral commission
like the Rockefeller it was made by The
Rockefellers Epstein was a member of it
actually but they're working towards
that same goal so I sort of you know
that is I see one power faction then you
sort of have in the the 80s like with
Iran Contra some of those people ended
up backing like under Reagan end up
backing Trump like you have him advised
by Edwin Meese you have Oliver North
supporting his campaign people like that
I think that particular power faction
isn't necessary I don't see them as
clean at all right but I do see them as
more like uh they prefer the Nationalist
model they want America to be top
they want you know American Empire to
continue and but they don't want to
share it with these other and they don't
want to build this like Global unified
thing they want like the uni unipolar
world to continue are you going to
continue
what do you mean do you have more to
answer my question well I'm just trying
to say I see Trump as that faction okay
does that help I'm sorry yeah but I want
you to go more because okay so let who's
ruined
many people's lives the last 20 years
let's make a list okay if we were to say
who's ruined many people's lives the
last 20 years uh we can put FBI there we
can put uh CIA there we can put
Clinton's there we can put CDC there we
can put NIH there you know we can put uh
China there we can put fauci there we
can put World economic Forum there we
can put uh you know you realize where
I'm going with this like I can we can
put Biden's family there we can put uh
McConnell we can put we can put so many
names on this list right
every one of those guys hate Trump
every one of them hate Trump why well
um
hmm exactly yeah but I don't think it's
necessarily because again you know I
think again the American public maybe
it's Hollywood for a long time sees
things as kind of black and white oh if
you know all the bad guys are against
this guy he must be good I don't I think
the real world doesn't really function
like that a lot you know by the time you
get to sort of be
rise to that level to an extent you have
to you know have made deals in the past
that aren't I don't disagree you know
what I don't disagree and like Trump's
Mentor Roy Cohn insanely dirty of course
insanely dirty you know and a lot of you
know the art of the deal he learned that
from Cohn who you know and Cohn had
learned it from generoso Pope who was
like this attack very close friend to
Frank Costello and the guy that ran the
cement industry concrete but everybody
in the everybody that's what no it's not
dirty I don't there's difference between
no there's a difference between dirty no
I disagree what I'm trying to okay so
for example this is where I'm going with
this to me uh I have a lot of people
that you would say are dirty okay and
somebody could make a very clear
argument that these people based on
their past are dirty okay and I've spent
a lot of hours with these guys
and when I sit down with them and I say
so tell me what happened that one time
when
let me tell you what happened when we
were in the room Paul Castellano he did
this and then all of a sudden Gotti said
this and that ended up oh wow okay got
it so hey when yourself when you were in
this situation and this one guy that was
robbing banks we had him on the thing
I'm like when you were doing this and
why why did you do this and how did the
bank fall for this and how were you able
to do this okay so how do we defend
against that right so
evil right now for example you know the
one of the biggest reasons why big
Pharma is doing what it's doing is take
advantage of people in America is
because the patent laws that we have
this whole hatchman and wax I think it's
the one of the senator from Utah is a
Republican and the other congressman is
from California who's a Democrat they
come together they lorta uh the the what
do you call it the patent Loft to 14
years and then in 1994 under Clinton
they raised it to 20 years and these uh
insurance companies come out with
medication and they can sell it for 20
years patent nobody else can compete
with them and the price point one of the
drugs we looked at uh Vinnie the price
point of what they sold and then the
year when uh what do you call it when
the patent expired within three years
the price of the medicine dropped 98 and
a half percent let me say this one more
time it went from a thousand dollars
to 15 bucks okay because now everybody
could compete in the marketplace so you
look at these laws you're like okay so I
can see why big Pharma would negotiate
and hire lobbyists to go in there to
pass the law to extend the patent for 20
years and then figure out other ways
some of them are extending them for
another 29 years 39 years okay that's
dirty let's figure out a way to
negotiate these policies what I'm asking
about here is okay these are all the top
10 list of organizations that are the
ones that have destroyed America the
most divided us the most had us fighting
against each other all of these guys
hate yeah the orange so you know so what
okay why is that well I think there's I
I guess I would say two things uh one in
my opinion I think more than anything
else these guys more than they hate
Trump I think they hate Trump's base
more than they hate Trump specifically
and I would argue that because of the
war on domestic Terror infrastructure
being set up freshly to Target people in
that base and also anyone that has sort
of nationalist
uh a nationalist bent I would guess I I
you know and Trump obviously postures as
being Nationalist and I don't think they
like that and in pushing to bring
industry back to the us all of that
stuff the decision was made explicitly
by the people who actually run America
to move industry out of the US many
decades ago they do not want to bring it
back
they don't and I think
um if you're if a lot of these people
like I mentioned earlier have this goal
of making this global economy and a lot
of that has since been wrapped into uh
agenda 2030 and the people actually
developing those policies
um I don't think they want a nationalist
guy there's a there's an effort globally
to really vilify nationalism it doesn't
matter if it's Trump it's also based on
our own Brazil or whatever sure and I
don't think you have to like them but I
think the reason they're so against them
is because they want to vilify
nationalism because if I have to choose
between nationalism and what's the
opposite of nationalism globalism
internationalism okay exactly
International if I have to choose
between being proud of my Heritage my
country my land and everybody else
around the world
give me a good argument would that being
a bad thing it's it's about sovereignty
I think though at the end of the day
because when you remove National
sovereignty then the people actually
running the show are even more on
account yeah so they'll use nationalism
to link it to Germany but again so so
here's what that's what has been going
on
people fall for their night but but
let's let's kind of go to this the
closest president I can find to Trump
closest family I can see to Trump as
John F Kennedy closest I think those two
to me are very close neither one of them
have a nice uh uh resume you know
they've done some stuff in the past you
know Kennedy all that stuff but both of
them the people of power like the Lyndon
Johnson the Hoover the CIA sure those
guys hated Kennedy totally okay the same
people hate Trump
Trump and Kennedy politically believe it
or not are more similar but you know
Kennedy was a proud Second Amendment NRA
member today Kennedy is not a Democrat
but it's a hero to a lot of Democrats oh
yeah so what I watched was the following
so here's a question for you Whitney the
question for you is this what
institution
has hurt America
that loves Trump
um
uh yeah that would probably take some
thinking to do at least in the U.S it's
pretty clear that by this that's what I
think you understand what I'm asking I
want you to think about it what
institution
what institution
that hates America that's hurt America
loves Trump
I can't even think of one I want you to
think about it because you're you're
more able to kind of see it from the
other side what institution
that's hurts um that has hurt America
the last 20 years loves and supports
storm
not from from that list that you sent
from the fauces give me another one
maybe I'm not thinking about anybody I
can't even I can't even think of one
great question I guess here's here's the
thing that really concerns me about
Trump as it relates to National
sovereignty recently he did an interview
and he said something about
um about Israel about how Israel
essentially he said it controls Congress
and how he thought that was a good thing
okay so regardless of how you feel about
Israel Zionism the US Israel
relationship I do not think it's a good
sign to have your nationalist
politicians say uh a foreign power
rightfully unduly influences our
National Congress
and in the if you look at the history
there are Israeli Espionage operations
that have happened Jonathan Pollard is
probably the best well-known where that
Gravely undermined U.S national security
and I think those institutions support
Trump but they're not necessary I can
give an argument today but give me one
more go one more go two more go three
more Adam you're here what are you
thinking you're saying that institutions
that give me any institutions or
individuals that have hurt America that
love Trump
I'm actually Curious by the way if
you're watching this comment below on
the hash debate each other I'm really
curious I don't know all the
institutions this isn't my world I mean
from the FBI this is you research you're
you you've been following politics for a
good 20 years you know you're in it what
is Rob yourself what what institution
I'm actually curious right now what
institution that's made our lives worse
that made people stay home during covet
that force people to do [__] they don't
want to do okay about covet though Trump
still is is really into operation warp
speed and what that produced okay
declines to distance himself from any
sort of the vaccine stuff fine so use
that one that's one so so he operation
warp speed that you try to speed up
getting vaccine but the reality is
Pfizer didn't announce that they got the
vaccine two days after the election
which didn't help him anyways yeah but
what I'm saying is I don't I don't think
that is that hurt Americans it was not a
good idea to put the military
specifically DARPA but people in charge
of that who have sort of DARPA tends to
have sort of this mad scientist View and
they have Partnerships with people like
moderna which also has partnered with
the bill Melinda games they support
Trump though I think they manipulated
Trump's support but Trump still to this
day supports that operation the warp
speed yeah I think yeah I think he and
he takes he takes credit for the fact
that he was able to get back then you
have Peter Navarro right saying oh he
so he was manipulate so it's possible
keep going okay so that's one keep going
give me a couple more well okay I'm not
an expert on on like Trump stuff
necessarily but I personally don't trust
any politician especially one that gets
to that level I do think though that it
is important in my opinion to push for
National sovereignty and things like
that what I mentioned with Israel that
does concern me because Israel's foreign
policy objectives or policy objectives
as it relates to United States do not
always coincide with American uh the
American national interests the Iraq war
is a huge example of that Netanyahu
being like positive reverberations
around the region you had the Wexner
Foundation which was tied up with Israel
at that time trying to develop talking
points to push us into Iraq and all of
this stuff and that cost American lives
cost American money obviously and all
sorts you know millions of innocent
people dead in in the Middle East not in
our national security interest and you
have a lot of I mean even the Trump
white house uh the FBI found Stingray
devices that were Israel's government
spying on the Trump White House nothing
was done and there's a lot of things
going back uh Robert Maxwell sold bugged
software on behalf of Israel to our nuke
facilities at Sandia Los Alamos lab Ken
Henry Kissinger told him who to pay off
nothing happened to Henry Kissinger John
Tower was the guy he paid off former
head of the Senate armed services
committee opened the door for Maxwell to
sell this bug software and then they
take our nuclear secrets and then they
sell it onto China so that is a problem
for me I mean you say that's one example
but I think that is a pretty significant
example and personally I would challenge
Trump on that when it comes to the
America First stuff but at the same time
when you're talking about
the uh you know the Republican Party one
out of 20 institutions you just
mentioned that's fine in terms of
undermining the claim of America first I
think that is something that he
definitely needs to address what I like
that you do I'm not you you you're
you're the pro here you're in the world
that you're in that you go in and you
find stuff right that's your job you're
very good at it I would be very curious
if you went
and you investigated the one guy that
was assassinated and the other guy that
was character assassinated in ways no
one's ever been character assassinated
before why is that why are those two
families feared as much as they were
feared is it because they were doing so
many side deals I don't think so no no
so so that's my so what I'm trying to
find out is because think about this
here's what we want to do
there's two ways to to to to to to
would we like to see more people who
love America that are not willing to
bend their backs for anybody and
negotiate anything just to be invited to
those cool parties okay yeah obviously
that would be better but is Trump that
guy I'm not saying if Trump is that guy
what I'm saying but but here's what I'm
saying to you I'm saying go investigate
him
and go write something on him and
Kennedy link those two families and then
rate them write whatever dirt or
anything you want to find but then also
ask why do these organizations if we
were to rank okay if we were to rank the
last 60 years 1964 1963 till today let's
go November of 1963 till today right
that's 60 years from the last 60 years
from your perspective give me the five
agencies individuals organizations that
have destroyed America the most the five
the top five oh man uh give me the top
five really putting me on the spot I
mean no I'm not saying you know exactly
what the top five but in your opinion
what do you think are the top five
um all right it's um
well I guess it's pretty broad uh a lot
of corporate America would be up there
for sure multinational corporations
um big Pharma uh IBM
um a lot of the big tech companies then
and now for sure okay big Pharma
building this transnational power
structure right at the end of the day
I'd like to throw the FED in there okay
Federal Reserve yeah okay game who else
or you can just broaden that and make it
Banks the big banks are the biggest
banks commercial corporate yeah I got
all that together what else would you
say uh definitely the CIA
Justice would you put doj over FBI like
how who how well doj oversees the FBI
technically yeah and FBI together how
about who else lobbyists
yeah but lobbyists are revolving door on
the payroll stuff so ultimately that's
the corporate side subverting the public
sector or military industrial complex
industrial complex in in terms of that
military-industrial complex in terms of
how people think of that I would say the
contractors General Dynamics insanely
corrupt that's the crown family yeah I
mentioned earlier they run that insanely
corrupt Lester Crown the Pentagon tried
to get his security clearance route
revoked three times and they couldn't do
it because higher-ups kept shutting it
down so perfect let's do this let's stay
on this this is very helpful let's
continue because I think this is good
okay so we got big Pharma we got IBM we
got fed
I would say big Tech big Tech is what
you would say okay big Tech then we said
the CIA the OJ FBA combined together
military industrial complex fine now
give me individuals what families
names the last 60 years since November
of 2000 to November of 1963 not 22nd
since November 1st of 1963. till today
which top families have destroyed
America okay Rockefellers yeah
um after that I put the Chicago families
up there the crowns and the pritzkers
I'd probably put them together yeah
Chicago got it who else
um foreign
[Music]
crisis the sacklers okay the sacklers
because that I mean a lot of not enough
people talk about that but that you can
sort of rope into big Pharma like some
of the big companies that are tied to
suspect stuff going on with the anthrax
attacks and also with covid stuff
um emergent biosolutions you know they
make a killing off of selling Narcan
they have a monopoly on Narcan too so we
got three Rockefeller the Chicago the
pritzker you put them together the
opioid the sacklers who else uh well
again I think you know when you're
talking about banking interest a lot of
these tend to be transnational you have
some of these old money Banks from
Europe
um give me names family
Rothschild yeah I'd probably put the
Rothschild on there for sure but they
openly made an alliance with the
Rockefeller it's not that long ago who
else
um these are just families probably
talking about individuals
or Clinton people who have sold America
well Kissinger sold America out
definitely yeah well I'm here because of
Kissinger you know that oh really I'm
I'm from Iran Kissinger was supposed to
help Iran the shot he didn't last minute
the shot fell and then catastrophic
issues happen hominy shows up and
there's six you know anyways that's a
whole different story so Kissinger who
else would you put us top for would you
put uh uh uh what are the names that we
want to say do we want to say Johnson
Lyndon Johnson yeah the bushes
Dulles yeah Alan Dulles the airport
Sullivan and Cromwell which is their Law
Firm that they ran foreign
I would think the clintons bushes bidens
they
they're different sides of just the same
crime especially the bushes and the
clintons there's too much weird stuff
around them especially when you look at
things like Iran Contra like I mentioned
earlier Bush covered for Mark Middleton
they like step in for each other when
they need to so here's my question you
ready all right so here we go okay which
one of these loves Trump yeah I don't I
don't think they do that's the point
yeah
who you today is I would love because my
I do so many different things right now
I wish I had time to do investigative
journalism I just don't have the luxury
to do it right now okay but that's why I
love for somebody like you who if this
interests you and if you're inspired by
it go do those two families sure okay I
do think you know if you're talking
about Trump specifically you know I do
think he has some conflicts of interest
and has for a long time I don't
understand
um yeah so you know at the end of the
day if the issue is let's stop the villa
qualification of nationalism let's make
moves to protect our national
sovereignty I think that has to be a
mass movement from the American public
because you know I see what you're
saying but at the same time I think so
many people in the United States whether
it's been instilled in them through
education or culture or whatever seem to
think that as long as we get the right
guy in the White House everything's
going to magically fix itself in this
country and I do not think that is
possible you know believe what you want
to believe about Trump he came in and
you know
2016 with great intentions and all of
that if you want to believe that I I
don't necessarily believe that but if
you do you know he wasn't able to do
that why you know one guy can't fix it
you know Robert F Kennedy Jr running
right now you know he's obviously very
different than a lot of these guys do
you think if he got in he could fix it
all I you know I think the problem is so
big at this point and that so many of
these institutions we've been naming off
it's the it's the most powerful
institutions in the U.S government you
know they said before you know like with
Nixon and Watergate oh it's just you
know some rotten apples in the barrel
but keep the barrel
I'm telling you the barrel is rotten and
the only way we can fix that in this
country is that people have to realize
that and people have to start taking
responsibility for their own what does
that mean because that's a good
motivational speech but what is it
here's what it means what is what is so
what do you need to be self-sufficient
as a community as an individual as a
family not relying on the government not
but also multinational corporations
right we have outsourced from our
communities from our country almost
everything we produce to foreign powers
that don't like us right or we're in you
know trillions of dollars in debt to our
ostensible main enemy so that I would
argue that's because we have our
government corporations but the American
people have co-signed it because they've
been told this is more convenient this
will be cheaper blah blah blah uh
outsourced so much of what we need to
survive as a people as communities as
families uh to people that don't like us
and that's not necessarily just China
here right that's these corporations uh
these Elite families that own own most
of corporate America and the banks and
what have you they don't like the little
people yeah so but I mean if you're
listening to this folks you're enjoying
this podcast smash the Subscribe button
and turn on the notifications and just
in case something happens your text
award podcast to
310-340-1132 text award podcast to
310-340-1132 for anything that we do the
next live event and maybe if you would
like to have a Whitney whip at a live
event at our studio in the future let us
know but Texas there will be announcing
the next live here as well let's
continue okay so I agree I think the
challenge is a couple different things
one is we think one person can save
America when is the next Kennedy when is
the next Reagan going to be here it's us
I fully agree with you it's us I agree
with you but I think people like you are
very important I think we need to
protect people like you because I think
people like you are a gem we need more
of you it takes a lot of courage and
sacrifice in your personal life to want
to study these types of topic this is
not an easy job and profession you've
chosen I salute you for the job that you
do to me it's a form of public service
and we're not paying taxes for a person
like you you're independent you're doing
this for us we thank you for it you're
very important I think individually we
need to stop relying on the government
so I think one of the things that is
anybody that pushed a lot of
entitlements the last 60 years and got
more Americans to be relying on the
government I think they screwed America
as well they got people not to realize
what their capabilities capabilities are
that's perfect but the problem here for
me
what I think immediately those are
long-term solutions for us to become
independent responsible not rely on a
government and take care of ourselves I
get it
but I also think this person we're
looking at to be able to get in there
and do the work is not going to be a
person that looks and walks and talks
the way you want that person well sure
but here's what I worry about too with
the 2024 election given how the other
elections have been what's going to stop
either side from being fraud right or
Russia get 2.0 or some other kind of
thing well the thing is our elections
the legitimate legitimacy of them is
already questioned by a massive portion
of the country after 2020. no but both
sides have been uh
the other side it'll be the other side
again you know what I mean that's
something both of them do and we just
have to accept the fact that when people
you know NFL well they cheated that's
who won the sir okay got it but let's
say Trump gets in the National Security
State and all these other institutions
hate him right and and they all put
their weight behind the fraud claim what
happens then to say well they cheated to
do oh oh yeah that there was cheating
that there was whatever foreign
interference I don't know I know we
don't know if it's going to happen but
my concern is I think we are we have
already really started to move away from
democracy that we are currently living
in illusion of democracy let's go back
to Republic where the individual is
protected because right now the
individual is not but think about the
DNC even in the primaries with Bernie
Sanders yeah they're cheating them I
mean they they screwed him totally yeah
right he was he was the guy and now
they're saying they won't even have a
debate debate in the Democratic primary
because the RFK Junior against Biden so
what's your solution though what's your
solution so so for example you're saying
what if we get this person Trump wins
and the santis wins okay what if we get
RFK then once what if we get you know
Biden demos we know what's going to
happen in Biden that's right we know
what's good yeah but if Trump wins and
he goes in or DeSantis when he goes in
there's a difference between those two
winning if Trump wins and he goes in
they're gonna try to do everything they
can and everything's been false Durham
report you know the recent thing
Clinton's involvement Obama's
involvement there's so many things that
have been proven that were fake The
credibility but what's been done what's
where's the accountability from who's in
his end from anyone's end all these
people I mean the the stuff that has
been these people have gotten away with
in an actual election interference
kidding me like you know who you know
who was enemy to state number one when
Trump was president
no I'm not talking I'm talking about
like the Russia gate stuff oh yeah and I
don't think I don't think I think and
honestly those guys are morons if they
keep doing that because that business
model is not working for them they keep
losing money when they do the MSNBC not
creative either I mean but the point is
let them do that they have they have no
moral Authority Democrats this guy was a
guy that believed in the Russia stuff
first time him and I spoke when I was
going to bring them here to be with us
on the team I didn't know if I was ready
for a guy like this I question I'm like
what do you think about this can you
reason are you able to do this well I
think I said what do you think about the
Russia deal eventually he came in and
now he reads it he says I can't believe
they did this so and he's a guy that is
a worker he's independent he doesn't
rely on the government he takes care of
himself he's done very well for himself
and now he's sitting there saying yeah I
don't know if I like I'm not a trump guy
but I don't know what they're doing here
there is more people in his Camp sure
and then can I just submit one thing we
talked about this list of Institutions
that have basically harmed America
the number one item on this list that we
left out is the media and mainstream
media and the lies the narratives if
they told the American public and I'm
the I'm the type of person that Prides
myself on digesting a whole appetite of
media especially now but
there's a there's a wide swath of
Americans that are just basically just
peripherally reading the news yeah I
guess this Russia gate thing yep I guess
they uh yeah the January 6th thing I
guess the Dominion thing there's it's
like we don't have time to basically
pick apart each of these stories like
we're all not with the web we can
diagnose all these wild different
stories and just accumulate them and
diagnose them most people are like yeah
I guess there's a Russian thing going on
Boom here's what concerns me though so
based on what you guys have been saying
and it's very true collapse in
mainstream media is collapsing and we're
in a very different position now than
2016 or really any other time as far as
that metric is concerned but what
concerns me is that okay so with covet
you had this huge push to turn
everything move everything to the
digital sphere right and at the same
time you're trying to move everyone
everything all stuff online but you're
also making this big push to control
what's online yeah and so you're having
this push uh to censor you know I get
Twitter files touched on that obviously
and there's this this talk from like
Matt taibi and others about the
censorship industrial complex that is a
very real thing and you know for someone
like me the threat of censorship is very
real you know I did Real uh factual
reporting on stuff going on with
covid-19 and I lost my patreon they
admitted that there was nothing untrue
in the report they censored me for uh
but they thought it might affect vaccine
uptake and so they took away all my well
Whitney doesn't it just all come down to
one word which is control it doesn't
want to control what you say they want
to control you spend your money they're
going to control your social credit
scores
into these digital systems everything's
going to be online or on the cloud or
whatever and at the same time they're
controlling they're making an
unprecedented push for control over that
digital sphere so we're being herded to
a place and they're creating all of
these all of this infrastructure to
control what we can see in here once
we're all stuck there essentially so you
have collapse and Trust of mainstream
media the goal it seems like is to take
out everyone that won't say what
mainstream media says and at the same
time you're having mainstream media
creepingly being replaced by a chat GPT
and things like that they're saying that
by 2025 90 of all the content media
content online is going to be chat GPT
generated right so you don't have
regular people telling you what to say
how are people going to know what's real
and what's not at that point and now
there's all this talk of deep fakes AI
art has gone into this new era you can
make anyone with a IR be in a picture
with Jeffrey Epstein you know what I
mean so you know this is a really
unprecedented situation and to think
that these institutions we've been
listing off those actors one want to go
you know throw the kitchen sink at us to
get what they want you know I think that
might be kind of naive to think that
because you know this is they're making
a total push for control
and they're going to put out all the
stops because if they don't get it they
lose right and stuff will start to come
out they don't want that to happen you
know so this is they're giving it their
all and I don't think they're going to
win at the end of the day but how much
damage do they cause they've only done
plenty of plenty of damage well and I
was going to say uh because Pat I think
it was the podcast about Giuliani in
them where we were talking about the
hope and having hope and having faith
not losing all that hope but just from
everything that we've talked about
winning from Epstein to these guys it's
like are we wasting our time I I 100
appreciate getting it out there getting
the word out there but are we wasting
our time in the sense that these people
have set up the pieces of the game where
no matter what we could literally just
like the whole the Durham report came
out FBI Department of Justice Obama
administration Hillary they all peddled
his lie the whole Russia it was all Bs
they framed Michael Flynn three star
general it just came out the reports in
your face nobody's gonna go to jail
Hillary is going to walk free nothing
happens so are we just wasting our time
with all these these all these just evil
players because not at the end of the
day what what really happens to them
yeah so the the lack of accountability
thing is a major problem and again I
think the main issue we need to be
looking here is public trust right
there's no public trust in the media
there's the public trusted institutions
is dwindling but what do those
institutions do when they realize no one
trusts them anymore
they don't know they're not going to
give up control easily you know what I
mean so what are they planning to do
and this is why I always go back to the
stuff that's been set up by the byte
Administration but it's antecedents go
before Biden this war on domestic Terror
infrastructure all of the people that
were counter-terror experts and
developing AI to hunt insurgents in Iraq
are now developing Ai and policies to go
after regular Americans that are accused
of domestic Terror and if you read the
policy papers from the bite
Administration their definition of what
is a domestic terrorist is extremely
broad it's extremely broad it includes
people who don't like uh even on the
left uh the advance of like multi-north
National corporations and like global
capitalism and stuff are people who are
perceived as being too anti-authority
and two anti-government or parents
speaking up at school board meetings
saying they don't want their kids uh
learning about sex and they're yelling
at those domestic terrorists so the
problem is you know how are they how are
they trying to do this it's with AI it's
with what it's data mining off of social
media I would say if people really want
to show shut down this machine get off
of Legacy social media okay yeah but
again like you know I know that's hard
for people because people are so into it
and like me as a journalist a lot of
people won't read my stuff if I don't
use it and blah blah but you have to
look at what they're setting up and they
wouldn't be setting up this war on
domestic Terror infrastructure where it
could be you unless they were planning
to use it at some point and all they
need Bill Barr said it uh a few years
ago when he was attorney general uh he
was talking about getting a backdoor in
encryption eliminating essentially any
sort of privacy enhancing technology for
the public he was saying at some point
there's going to be a a big event that
will Galvanize public opinion around
these issues sort of reminds me about
the peanut new Pearl Harbor stuff before
9 11 you know
um but it's true you have this one
crisis that comes and there's all this
fear this is the Boogeyman this is what
we had to do to stop it because if you
think like I mentioned earlier we're
being herded into this Corral of you
know the digital control grid I guess
and they're trying you know and
historically what I think it's the
carrot in the stick you know what I mean
yeah I'll totally get that and it
explained very clearly
but you know
um
you know the whole thing when some
people say well you know what if you
only had one hour to live what would you
do
look dude if I had one hour to live I
wouldn't be here right now I'd stay home
do that
so let me get this straight for the rest
of the year you want me to treat
my life as if I only have one hour to
live yeah I'd be home for the entire
year
so is that what you want me to do well
no still be effective but what if you
had one hour to live dude I get that and
I've said this myself it's an element of
this is why I think I'm working too hard
this is why I'm doing this gocha so
there's so many arguments with
contradictions that we all give our
parents told us we tell our kids we tell
our audience you know the media tells us
leaders tells us books the world is
filled with a lot of contradictions and
somehow some way we have to find some
level of reasonable decision for us to
make that comes with contradictions for
example
you know this whole thing's like well
why we you know one person is not going
to save this and it's not it's not it's
got to be us
okay I think that's partially true
long term it's got to be us yeah but it
was one person that was able to have the
courage to go against Hitler
and it wasn't Chamberlain it was another
guy named Churchill
and if there is no Churchill
with the fearlessness that he had no
matter how much [__] you talk about his
past how he was who you know husband you
know
if there's no Churchill you and I are
probably speaking German right now but
the world will be a different world
today okay every once in a while during
times like this you still have to have
somebody speak on your behalf no I'm not
sure a lot of people like follow your
content they feel like you're speaking
for them so why why do you do so well
because there's millions of people
around the world that are saying dude
she's speaking she's she's me I feel
like she's talking on my behalf great I
think we need somebody that's going to
get up there and piss a lot of people
off when I see candidates that are
already broker and deals with everybody
pre-election I already know that
person's not going to do what American
needs to do today I already know that
person going to get into the White House
and they're going to do what hey I'm
into the White House on this yeah you
know the person to do that I still do
believe because the the angle of just
thinking it's us that that gets us from
not trusting in the voting system
and even if you show up to vote here's
what I mean when I say you know the one
guy thing one guy can't save it because
what happens is a lot of people feel
like oh as long as I vote for that one
guy and he gets in then I don't have to
do anything I don't agree with more yeah
but that's how a lot of people react
okay so I'm not saying we shouldn't you
know they're no good you're not getting
a good guy or a better guy in the White
House you don't I don't no but there are
people that do that and so that's why I
try and stress in my work especially in
today's climate I mean there's this
crazy banking crisis going on and it's
not going to get better before it gets
worse sure right so what do you do
tomorrow if you wake up and uh your
money's gone right what are you gonna do
are you going to feed your family what
if the internet's shut down you know all
this I mean I encourage people to think
about that type of building that type of
resilience in their lives because the
the less dependent you are in the system
the less the harder it is for you to be
enslaved by that system 100 you know so
that's what I'm trying to say about you
know personal responsibility and stop
Outsourcing your needs to the these
people in this system right would it be
better to get someone who who speaks
truth to power into the White House I'm
not saying it's that would be bad at all
what I'm saying is a lot of people tend
to go back you know to sort of armchair
activism or you know political season's
over I'm not going to fight for my
rights anymore because now I've got the
guy up there I do think and that's a
problem with somebody to speak on your
behalf yes sir but the problem is a lot
of people like to not do anything you
know what I mean the reality is the
predo theory has been around for a while
the 80 20 ruled 80 is not going to do
anything anyway so we're not relying on
the 80 to do something I've been part of
the 80 when I was trying to get
everybody else to save my life and I'm
like this [__] doesn't work I want to be
part of the community that can stand up
and be responsible for themselves and I
shifted that's I had a 1.8 GP in high
school trust me there's no one in high
school that's going to say Patrick but
David was going to do something big with
his life finally I'm like get off your
ass and go do something I joined the
army at 18 life change so I'm I'm with
you there but I also do believe the this
notion like you know how single men and
women who wait until they get married
what's the problem the older you get
what is the problem are you married I
don't know if you're married or not
married with kids okay so I'm a single
mom okay okay so so the whole concept
with marriage right the whole concept of
marriage
um you wait to get married okay wait
till uh 35. with your 40.
with your 45 way 250 what's the problem
the longer we wait until we get married
what are we really saying to the world
what we're really saying to the world is
what I'm gonna wait until I find what
the perfect person guess what good luck
the older you get the harder it's going
to be to find that perfect person right
so there is part of that argument that
also has a leak in it there is risk in
marriage right there is risk in having
kids there's risk in saying I think this
guy could be the right guy but it's even
riskier to say no no no no no I'm not no
no no no no I'm not going to do this
there's risk you know there's risk
relationships don't work you know kids
don't there's there's pain in that stuff
so I think for us the one part I
absolutely agree with that we got to
take full responsibility I think the
other part is as well hey who do you
think that is the least corrupt person
that is not loved by the corrupt
institutions that you think could go and
fight these corruption that has the
highest likelihood try to support that
person if you think it's a RFK go for it
if you think it's tulsive but if you
think it's a even a Libertarian guy we
had a guy named Dave Smith yeah I
actually like this guy I hope he does
something if it's a Dave Smith go for it
if you think it's a trump go for it if
you think it's Vivek board but find
someone that you think could fight that
corruption what I like about vivec is
he's ran a company that's worth a couple
billion dollars and he's calling out all
the [__] he's calling out all these
weird institutions support a guy like
that so do be independent but also do
sell and support the guys that you think
have the highest likelihood of fighting
the things that you also want someone to
fight for I think both are necessary
sure yeah yeah sure so okay well you
know but I mean the only thing I would
say is like you know if you have more
limited means limited finances I would
personally think it would make sense to
invest in I don't know your a resilient
food supply for you and your family and
things like that before donating instead
of donating at all what I mean I'm not
this actually wasn't a I wasn't trying
to raise money for anybody and I'm never
going to get into politics because I'm
not I'm not born here I don't have any
interest for being a governor I enjoy
building businesses you know will we do
something to advise and all this other
stuff we're already doing that anyways
and indirectly with certain camps that's
a different story but for me it's more
about your dinner table so what do you
think about this let me tell you what he
made me think about what do you think
about these institutions I think that is
a form of support I think dinner table
lunch coffee conversation supporting the
rhetoric that you think is important
sure in the the talking thing
maybe the the
values and principles that you think are
most important like you know you ask
somebody a question so what did I can
say last week the biggest threat to the
United States of America are white
supremacists seriously really so let me
get this straight so if I'm voting for
Biden
and you're saying the most important
serious threat is white Americans that
are apparently white supremacists that
don't go along with your philosophies I
mean if you think you agree with that
vote for them support them if you don't
don't that's just a way of you know
supporting or not supporting that uh
argument but Pat do you think okay so
let's say another person like that grows
to this this this power becomes wants to
be the president we want you don't think
that the powers that be we already saw
it I do think that they're going to I'm
saying they're all gonna go after this
person but but they're not going to let
them okay okay so what's the alternative
well that's my point that's why I was
going to where's the alternative look
the the more you win in life you trust
fewer people because more people rip you
off more people backstab you it becomes
harder to trust people it takes longer
to trust people you're not as open as
you once were when you were not even
innocent you see the way people take
advantage of you you're like oh my God I
did that for that guy why did I gotta
take advantage of me what a freaking
Shady situation now you're like you know
what screw it I don't trust anybody
right when you're moving up okay so what
are you gonna do sit by yourself and not
go entertain other no so I think when a
person gets involved in power like that
they're going to be tainted they're
going to see the darker side they're
going to see the gamification against
them you chose this job you shouldn't
have chose this job then don't do it you
chose to be a parent being a parent does
not like hey all these pictures you do
for you know annual for Christmas party
cards look how great they look you just
saw one second of the photo shoot of
three hours what you didn't see the two
hours and 59 minutes is fighting
throwing a fit pooping changing clothes
all the [__] that happens in a photo
shoot same thing's gonna happen as well
but we can't give up hope to say well
there's nothing I can do about it and
you know I'm helpless and I don't I
don't matter I don't know that's what
cowers do that's what victims do and the
DNA of an American is not a coward it's
not a victim it's somebody that has hope
and goes and fights for them well that's
why I talk about personal responsibility
I mean this is supposed to be a country
of people that like went out to the
Frontier and like we're self-sufficient
and and built something right but I
think Americans today have been
conditioned to be very different than
that and I think it's high time that
people return back to the values of the
from you know which this country came
from which includes the values of the
Constitution but also that those values
of self-sufficiency because if you're
not able to depend on yourself or people
you trust for something you're depending
on someone else and that person you know
you want to eat you've got to jump
through these hoops I mean that's not
given what we're seeing being built
around us today I do not think that is a
good way to continue to live personally
so you know I definitely agree with that
about values uh for sure but at the same
time
um like I said earlier I think too many
people to put too much of their faith
and too much of their energy in just
wanting one person to do everything for
them magically you know a per like a
political savior type of thing and I
think that Dynamic is very uh especially
especially at this point uh harmful it's
time for people to make something of
themselves or do something in the real
world to protect their family I mean
liking stuff on Twitter retweeting
that's not activism that's not
necessarily going to change the lowest
level though it's it's a form of it
people that do that and they're like oh
well that's right you know guess what I
think I would rather take that than
below that which is doing nothing
because you're hopeless and you're
hopeless that's that's worse than
somebody that does a return but a lot of
those hopeless people too are like I see
this whole system I think it's all
rigged right fine I'm talking to those
people and I'm saying you don't have to
participate in the system yeah you know
you can still do something about this
that doesn't involve interacting with
that system that's selfish I think
that's selfish well if you're building a
parallel system to keep you and your
family and your community resilient in
times of Crisis I don't think that's
selfish I think that's I think that's
what happened during the Great
Depression let me let me correct myself
I think there you need to be selfish 70
of the time but I 60 to 70 percent of
the time I do think you need to be
selfish and make those decisions for
yourself but the additional 20 30 40
where you need to be selfless I think
you need to also be thinking long term
because you don't matter as much as you
think you matter meaning you have kids I
have kids we matter but you're
officially living for
your kids in a different way than you
when you were single life changes
slightly right so we have to be thinking
about what we need to do for them do we
want to teach them to be Fighters do we
want to teach them to be willing to not
give up and you know have this mindset
like you know we have a guy that uh
comes to uh Mario's wedding one of the
relatives that comes to Mario is waiting
in our backyard
is from the other side of the family
it's like well you know uh these rich
people you know there's nothing I can do
about it you know there's some people
we're poor sometimes here Patrick is
Rich there's nothing we can do about it
Patrick grew up in a freaking his dad's
a 99 Cent Store cashier what do you mean
you cannot do anything about it
Patrick's a military guy that got out
not having a clue what the hell to do he
decided to read a few thousand business
books and life change this concept of
what I don't really matter that much I
think that's also catastrophic I want
people to read every single thing you've
written and say I want to do something
about this I want to rise up and risk my
life to contribute and fight these mofos
yeah absolutely I go I want to brawl I
want to be a Whitney Webb that's what I
want to do we need a hundred Whitney
webs right now we need more boys and men
around the world even 14 year old kids
15 year old kids that are saying I want
to go do some proper investigation we'll
go light it up and go think and you know
point out different arguments so for me
hero making machine I think you're a
hero I'm edifying you as a hero I think
we need more people to want to be
there's different ways of becoming a
hero I think you're one of the ways of
becoming a Hero Let's address one thing
has nothing to do with this uh Woody
Allen I I want to talk about this
because a lot of things been coming up
with Woody Allen and you know Vinnie
brought a video at Vinnie if you want to
even read the story with Woody Allen I
think it's on page delete on that I'm
pretty sure when he knows something go
from there yeah okay so um The Wall
Street Journal published uh an analysis
of recently released documents that
provided uh details of Jeffrey Epstein
contacts with high profile individuals
from 2008 uh with the guilty place
that's soliciting and procuring a minor
for prostitution all right they included
thousands of pages of emails uh
schedules from 2013 and 2017 which show
the nature of the frequency of these uh
Epstein's contacts with the array of
power for people they included Lawrence
Summers a former treasury secretary and
one time Harvard University president
who met with Epstein and Harvard uh
after Harvard decided it would no longer
accept his donations and Woody Allen
oscar-winning movie director who
attended dozens of dinners with his wife
SUNY who's his adopted daughter and he's
he's 87. she's 87 and he's I'm sorry
he's 87 she's 52. so like almost a 40
year it's yeah yeah it's disgusting and
FD at Epstein's mansion and if I'd ever
seen to film screenings other figures
include billionaire Adventure capitalist
and Linkedin co-founderie Hoffman former
Israeli uh prime minister uh what Barack
and Leon black billionaire co-founder of
private Equity a giant Apollo Global
Management so yesterday I was I was
doing you know research for for having
you on and uh just reading up and then I
saw a clip of uh Mia Farrow who was you
know the she adopted yeah her and Sunni
Previn and her daughter Dylan and
Pharaoh was a a molested was molested
and you know when you're when you're
doing this type of research I came up to
a a clip of the 90s of elite uh like a
tapped I haven't listened to it but I've
heard it so and I showed it to Pat
yesterday I I got emotional in this prep
meeting because it's Mia pharaoh and
Woody Allen's on the phone and she's
telling disturbing it's I'm gonna get
emotional right now she's she's crying
mind you this is her adopted daughter
yeah and describing what the the rape
and the abuse that he did to a
seven-year-old girl and Pat heard this
and he was in shock we had to hear it
twice so if it's right this is a tapped
phone call from Woody Allen talking to
me or pharaoh and this is they're
talking about Dylan who was the
seven-year-old at the time
[Music]
how could you do that to her
I don't know anything of that kind I
know what Dylan tells me you've told me
nothing but lies Dylan tells the truth
and consistently
no I don't know that Woody I've always
always worked been worried about you and
tell him
and I didn't know the doctor had to
report this to the authorities
[Music]
kissing Mommy didn't help me
like that
you would wait inside
and you would just want to be dead
because I don't know how you can live
with what you did
[Music]
so yeah yeah that is so disturbing yeah
you hear something like that I can't
it's just and these people nothing
happens Pat no jail Woody Allen's
walking around this poor girl's ruined
for her whole life the Epstein Island
all those girls all those kids no
accountability these people just walk
nothing happens two people got in
trouble Cindy McCain in January 2020
went in front of she was in front of a
stadium full of people she said we all
knew what Jeffrey Epstein was doing yeah
all these people knew so all these
people like after he was arrested acting
like oh yeah well I didn't know and it
was just money this I mean I can't this
is why I get frustrated with the Wall
Street journals reporting because it's
just like they didn't even mention Woody
Allen how how he uh married SUNY Previn
they don't mention Dylan Farrow at all
Noam Chomsky gets called out about it
he's supposed to be this Progressive
icon and he's like Woody Allen's a great
artist yeah don't ask me about my
evening with a great artist and a
convicted pedophile I mean it's just um
I mean it you know it it's disgusting
and frankly you know in my book I talk
about how these types of operations
whether it's you know whether it's
Epstein whether it's the Franklin
Scandal this stuff has been going on for
a really long time and even people that
are xcia like John kiriaku have said
like yeah like when we want to you know
recruit a source if they ask for a kid
to sexually abuse we give it to them
why do we do that and this is why I get
you know it's so frustrating because
Americans have been sold a vision of
their government a vision of their
intelligence community and Military that
is so divorced from this and I mean I
just think it's really time that you
know do we really represent the values
that we project around the world that
we're supposed to have internalized uh
or no I I don't think we do because
we've allowed our country to be run by
literal monsters and criminals and
people act like it's fine and you know
as long as we act like you know oh well
you know there's nothing I can do about
it no there is stuff you can do about it
and the first step is to get angry yep
by the way is that the clip that she was
talking about
yes can you play that yep can you play
that
it hides in plain sight Epstein was
hiding in plain sight we all knew about
him we all knew what he was doing we had
no one no um
legal aspect that would go after him
they were afraid of him for whatever
reason they were afraid of him there's
no direct McCain Biden tie so her saying
that means the whole freaking Senate
knew yep and nothing was done
I mean it's just crazy to me it's scary
and like I'm and so so anywhere me and
Patrick syrians were Christians that's
when and when I get to that point where
I'm like nothing happens to these people
they always get away with it I mean
Epstein and Galena the two that you know
they had those who had to be in trouble
but as a Christian the only good feeling
that I have that if there is a hell
these people will go there because in
Matthew I think it's chapter 18 Matthew
says if anybody God said or Jesus said
if anybody messes with these Innocents
of the kids it's better for them to Taya
Milestone around their head and throw
themselves in the ocean that's the only
comforting feeling it has is that if you
do that the government's not going to go
after you obviously they're all
protected that God will get these people
one yeah the thing is why are we
allowing a government that signs off on
this crap and you know an elite that
want to go to a guy that does stuff like
that for money so they can like you know
evade some taxes or you know make a
couple millions or this and that they're
willing to like co-sign this behavior
for that why do the American people not
get mad and enraged about it I mean it
drives me crazy one of the reasons I
went and moved to South America is
because so I'm 33 a millennial when I
was I left when I was in my early 20s
because I knew about a bunch of crazy
crap happening and everyone my age was
like I don't care as long as I have
Netflix and beer
and I mean there's a lot of Americans
that are still like that now you know
and it's just so
um I don't know I mean it makes me
really upset because you know I I was
really close to my grandparents they
loved this country so much and if they
only knew
if they only knew about this stuff I
mean I'm just glad they died before God
Rest their souls it's just so sad
that's that's why I think you're
inspiring a lot of other people that
want to be like you may not like I say
the first step is to get angry so many
Americans have been you know we're
stimulated all the stuff with like these
action movies and death and sex and
whatever the first step is to like stop
being so desensitized and and get angry
and and outraged about what's happening
and what's happening to all I mean when
you're talking about Epstein or like
Woody Allen these are kids I mean Dylan
Farrow was seven but court documents say
he was sexually interested in her but
time that between the ages of two and
three years old this is a guy people
call a great artist and parade around
and defend it's sick and I mean two
adopted kids they were I mean SUNY
Previn was his daughter too there's
pictures of them cuddling when they were
she was like eight or nine
nobody gives a damn yeah yeah because
you know oh he's a great artist blah
blah well Epstein was a great financier
or whatever so you know it doesn't
matter I mean once you do that stuff you
cross a line and it's been a Taboo it's
been a red line for thousands of years
for a reason you know and it shouldn't
change now so the question becomes out
of these 10 institutions
these 5 10 15 names that we came up with
which one of them protects guys like
Woody and Epstein the most well
supposedly you know law enforcement in
this country is supposed to prosecute
this stuff and they don't and they're on
the take
I think so who are they accountable to
that they don't do that because they
also answer to somebody where they see
it as a risk to go after a guy like
Woody Allen or Epstein well
it's hard to know
attorney with Alex
Secretary of Labor he was told he had to
sign off on the sweetheart deal because
Epstein belonged to intelligence and he
was told to back off it's above his pay
grade so you can assume that people like
that
pop up all over the place it doesn't
matter where you were in the government
and I agree with her Pat going going to
the mark Middleton think about this that
was in Arkansas where he's hanging from
a tree shotgun chest shotgun to his
chest no gun and they rule it the the
police department then it's a suicide
and nobody says that nobody says time
out how how is that possible you know
what I mean well no one even in the
media even bothers to look into who Mark
Middleton was no at all I just told you
all this China Gate stuff he's in you
just search on Congress you know the
Congress investigate investigation
Senate reports Mark Middleton's all over
it no one even brings up not even the
Daily Mail brings up China Gate no one
wants to touch that stuff and it's
because you do that you're going to get
into this murky world where like there's
Southern Air transport there's weird
arms deals going on someone's making a
lot of money and our intelligent
services for a very long time have been
very involved in illicit arms deals and
illicit drug trades and the banks too
HSBC got caught lawn during millions of
dollars for Mexican drug cartels no one
goes to jail none of them Sam bankman
freed with FTX is about to get 10 of the
13 charges dismissed against him and he
was the only one arrested for FTX
supposedly taking Ukraine Aid money and
then funneling it back to DNC
politicians nothing happens
I mean there's so many examples of this
it's totally mind-boggling and like I
point out in the first part of my book
actually a lot of Wall Street is hugely
dependent on the returns from laundering
drug money if the drug trade globally
stopped the banks would collapse it's
crazy
there is so much corruption here it's
just totally mental and until we realize
the extent of the problem we'll never be
able to fix it because if you have a you
know a Disneyland version in your head
of what the problem is you're not the
solutions you offer are not going to be
tailored to the actual problem nothing's
going to get fixed you know and for a
lot of people it's hard for them to wrap
their mind around this stuff how are
these people that I idolize like Woody
Allen put out in front of me as this
great guy blah blah and it clashes with
the reality so intensely people develop
cognitive dissonance
why would he be why would he have been
so promoted and so praised after doing
all of that
well our institutions are fundamentally
corrupt and they reward Behavior like
this if you're in the right clubs and
hang out with the right people and and
that type of stuff doesn't bother them
we should be deeply Disturbed As
Americans that there is a major segment
of very powerful Elite actors that think
that type of behavior is fine
and if they get caught nothing will
happen to them exactly that's okay
that's actually scary yeah but if you're
like I don't know a kid in Florida and
you get caught with a joint by the wrong
cop
foreign
but Woody Allen can molest two kids and
it's fine you know let me let me ask you
questions there's just a huge double
standard you know I think that's pretty
clear I'd be curious to know what you
say about this you know how uh people
run for office and they run for you know
president or whatever it is and they run
on different issues right build a wall
I'm with her Obamacare affordable health
you know health insurance like you know
uh cost of insurance you know
immigration taxes rich people top one
percent billionaires all these things
they run on
you think if somebody ran and they laid
out their top 10 plan and you know one
of the things in the top five is to
investigate what's really going on with
these issues you think that would be
something that would be uh resonate with
millions of Americans that they would
want to get to the bottom of this yeah I
think so because even today despite all
the mainstream media like missing
disinformation about stuff like Epstein
people are like I'd really like to see
that Client List you know
[Music]
uh and I think that's the reason the
only reason they ended up going after
galane Maxwell was because like they
were at first they were like well
Epstein's dead it's gone away you know
people were like but galane Maxwell
and I mean that public concern didn't go
away a lot of these institutions feel
like they have to maintain a public
veneer that like they'll do something
about it even though they're not really
doing much about it but what concerns me
is what happens when I mean the mask is
almost totally off as far as like the
FBI and doj is concerned right now what
happens when it comes totally off and
they don't even have to maintain that
public veneer if we're in accountable
responsible institution that cares about
democracy and the rule of law
I'd be so curious to see if somebody
runs on that
runs on that but by the way whoever runs
on wanting to investigate Epstein has to
be somebody that doesn't need Wall
Street money
whoever runs on wanting to find out
who's on the Epstein list oh wow can
only do it if they don't take any money
from Wall Street yeah
which means it eliminates 95 percent of
candidates yeah I was gonna say sure
okay by the way you know who's on that
list that doesn't need Wall Street money
Vivek doesn't need Wall Street money
Trump doesn't need Wall Street money a
couple other guys don't need Wall Street
money everybody else needs Wall Street
money what about RFK
he's he's a what he's like a 5 10 20
million Auto guy uh he's gonna need some
money you know
he's he's already gone after big Pharma
so that's a that's a very big thing to
go after and now he's continually
calling out the CIA for killing JFK yeah
to me every day there's a new article
written or a new clip of him saying the
CIA killed my uncle I think he's another
guy I think he's a wild card but I think
he's another guy
um I think he's another guy that again
remember what what for me
if you if you did a book The Cover is
half the page Trump half to Page Kennedy
okay John what do those two families
have in common you just kind of go
through it to see The Good the Bad the
Ugly the corrupt anything that you want
to go investigate the link to Kushner
family all this other family
if you see whatever family didn't need
money is the family that typically
cannot be controlled whoever can be
moved by money I mean you realize bidens
are doing what they're doing for a
million dollar check you realize how
pathetic that is that you can buy
bideness for a million or 10 million
dollars you know what 10 million dollars
is to some of these guys what 10 million
dollars I can buy your family for 10
million bucks and the big man's gonna
get the big guy's gonna get 10 percent
I I I think it's
it's concerning to put somebody like
that in power so I do think there's a
few people there we'll see what's going
to happen with that what are your
thoughts on that
well you know when it comes to someone
like Joe Biden I think there's a clip of
him that was going around in the primary
he was saying something like
um you know I wanted to be a politician
sooner but I had to wait to be old
enough so I could like sell out properly
something like that who said this uh
Biden but this was like a long time ago
in the when he was much younger
um you know because apparently they want
to take him seriously when he was too
young or something and he had to wait
I don't know I mean the American
political system the way it has operated
for decades rewards Behavior like that
you know and the problem is how do we
shift it away so it doesn't reward that
behavior and if you're looking at like
we mentioned earlier the DNC is going to
stop debate essentially to shoehorn
Biden in after they've done two
successive presidential primaries where
they essentially committed fraud to keep
the popular candidate out
how Democratic is that you know and I
mean
all this other stuff going on all this
funny games to try and like stop Trump
or you know
influence elections I love this stuff
that's I love the fact that rfk's in it
now that you brought him up I love the
fact that vivex in it I love the fact
that Trump's in it I love the fact that
the scientists even what he's doing
right now with the protecting the
conservative values and he's pissing a
lot of people off uh and I love the fact
that tulsi's also around how Tulsi does
something as well there's enough people
that are not afraid by the way Tulsa is
going to be on the podcast this Saturday
Saturday Saturday she's going to be on
the podcast so she's another person
that's uh out there going out there and
you know calling people out we need more
people like that and they're from all
sides rfk's running as a Democrat
you know uh uh Tulsi I don't know what
she's going to be doing whether she runs
as an independent or republican she's
also a necessary voice Vivek is sitting
there taking a completely different
angle on the ESG and the woke side you
know and then Trump's doing what Trump
is doing the center is doing what he's
doing more of these voices exposing them
no I'd be curious who's gonna say
specifically Epstein's list well I I
don't know but I think the more rhetoric
raising awareness of what's going on
whether it's ESG or Epstein or whatever
is important because it's it's really
really really important that a large
enough percentage of the American public
realizes something is seriously
seriously wrong because if we wait too
long and people don't figure it out
things could get much worse than they
necessarily need to be you know
and I would just really hope that um you
know that's what my hope with the the
upcoming campaigns are of all this with
with these different voices a lot of
whom are already coming out and being
very you know anti-system at least in
the rhetoric and that speaks to the fact
that a lot of people in the public are
very hungry for that type of rhetoric
and so that does give me uh hope that
people want a real change not just like
an Obama hope and change hopium uh type
of solution you know because that
we found out later that this whole
cabinet was picked by by my like City
Group in Wall Street uh right after the
08 crisis and stuff you know troubling
stuff so well Whitney first of all it's
it's always my sister says she's you're
her favorite guest okay she's listening
you're her favorite guest like can we
just have around regularly every week
folks if you love today's podcast and
you would like us to bring her back
again and again in the next three six 12
months especially with the election
stuff's getting deeper give us a sub and
go order both of our books the links are
below order the first one and a second
one do yourself a favor get smarter and
then whatever she writes about and
they're investigative she openly tells
you go look at the links go investigate
if I'm telling the truth go see if these
things are just from regular websites
and regular blogs or not but highly
recommend you order one nation under
blackmail volume one and volume two get
smarter get wiser and follow all her
content she's also got the podcast link
if we can put that below as well so they
can follow more closely and I think
you're speaking this weekend at the
Bitcoin event so I am those who are in
town you're going to get a chance to
hear speak as well with that being said
thank you so much for coming out and uh
this was awesome as usual thanks
have a good great one everybody uh we'll
do this again Saturday Saturday morning
take care bye bye-bye